While the results,
five,
four,
three,
two,
one,
boom.
And we're live ladies and gentlemen to
fight companion.
It's me.
Brian counts on the way,
but it's his birthday and uh,
he's old as fuck and sometimes you get
older,
you lose your keys and you don't know
what time it is.
Chip [inaudible] mother fucking Bra.
Um,
and Brendan job is up in this bitch.
Shut up and we're watching beltre hope
no one at the UFC gets mad,
but it's a big fight.
This is an important one.
What we are,
um,
right now this is the heavyweight finals
is going to be fade or versus Ryan
Bader.
I'm excited for that.
I am excited about that.
I'm very,
so I like Ryan Bader at heavyweight.
He looks fucking fantastic.
He's bigger than me right now.
How many of these guys just should have
done that a long time ago when to stop
cutting weight?
Went to heavyweight,
could just crucifying their body.
Chris Weidman I think is kind of one of
the main ones.
Do you think so?
I think he's going to excel at light
heavyweight.
He's got a disc replaced in his neck.
He's fucked up,
but I'll figure it out.
The worst nightmare though,
for a fighter in wrestling or MMA is
just being overpowered by somebody.
Right.
That's why they're killing themselves.
They just want to,
they would rather go in there,
uh,
depleted then get thrown around.
It's so old school.
It's such an old school way of thinking.
I feel like it makes sense though,
a little bit.
I mean to be that one in wrestling it's,
but look,
I was looking at Tj dillashaw,
Tj dillashaw.
Oh yeah,
but that's hard to say.
Let's go.
Let's talk about that fight because I
watched that fight several times.
I am of the opinion that was a quick
stoppage.
Early startups for sure.
Here's my,
here's my other point with that.
When there are 125 pounds,
you can let it go on a little longer
than if they were heavyweights.
I'd heard more on the side of let it go
long to 125 days.
It could be a thousand pounds each and
that fight got stopped quick.
Let that's fucking fine.
Especially when talking about a legacy
that was spending 69 bucks.
How about Tj?
Tj,
Nike.
See fight,
that guy drained his body to get down to
125 pounds.
Hey,
don't get me wrong though,
Henry.
To who knows a bad motherfucker.
He probably have beat him anyway.
But for people that are paying for the,
the event,
we want to see some highlight shit.
Definite knock out.
We don't want to,
you know,
I thought I thought the ref,
whoever he was,
he was just in the beginning.
You could tell he wanted to stop it.
Or like there's guides that they just,
they just want to get in there and like
saved her life.
He's a really good of anybody's life.
Made a mistake.
Look,
it's fucking hard to do.
It's a hard job.
I am so glad I'm not a referee because
when they make a mistake,
they can't say,
oh,
I fucked up.
Let's do it again.
You remember they used to be able to,
do you remember when big John McCarthy
stopped the fight between Marilla
Bustamante and uh,
Matt,
uh,
Fuck Matt Lindland,
Matt Lindland.
Matt Lindland tapped and said he didn't
tap and Big John McCarthy let the fight
continue.
Matt and he got him in an arm bar.
Oh Damn.
We missed an arm bar.
That was some serious Jujitsu.
Right.
Well,
we'll see it in the highlights.
Where was Jesus Christ talk.
Yeah,
let's get those nice.
Hey Bella towards got some fucking high
level fights now man.
They are like,
uh,
on,
on the way up there as close to the UFC.
You can get right.
They have the biggest prospect in the
sport and Pico.
Yeah,
it's by far.
Take it back a little bit.
What about Conan Sylvia era versus
soccer?
Fucking rob.
I remember that Shit,
man.
Same Shit.
He redid the fight.
The whole fight got re did old school.
They got stopped during John too and
then they decided,
you know what,
let them fight again.
Big John.
He got he eight or Conan hit,
um,
Sakharova soccer but dropped and went
down for a single and they stopped the
fight and he's like,
what the fuck you doing?
But it was in Japan.
They pulled him aside in Japan.
It's like wild west,
Bro.
You know,
like,
no,
I don't know why they don't let big
John's score the rounds.
That's tight.
I don't know why they don't let them
chime in on officially with a scorecard
until everyone else gets going.
The problem with that doesn't want to do
it.
The problem with that is who does what.
When I did it,
the problem was when they announced the
unofficial scorecard and if I was right
and you know the general consensus was
on my side and they flash it.
If,
if the,
if the other fighter wins,
do those judges get trash
responsible show.
But this is this.
No,
this is what it was though.
You know,
in the beginning the UFC was,
you know,
bending over backwards for the
commission.
Just,
you know,
just,
cause I had to,
well they still want the cat too,
but boxing's boxing doesn't have to do
that.
Boxing doesn't have to bend over
backwards for the commission.
Boxing was around before the commission,
so boxes,
because I have to kiss ass to the
commission.
The UFC had to because they were a new
sport and the commission could have
easily just shut it down.
So it was a different dynamic.
But the difference is you were doing it
as an independent,
meaning you weren't doing commentary.
So we were doing commentary and you were
coming in in between rounds.
It was very educational.
If big John was doing it,
the problem would be that he's actually
doing commentary while he's doing it.
That's very hard to do.
I'm not a fan of doing that because when
I'm doing commentary,
I'm telling you what's happening,
but really what I'm trying to do is be
entertaining.
I'm trying to give some life to it.
I'm trying to like put some emotion to
it,
but I'm not really scoring.
No,
I'm not saying that,
but I'm,
I'm not saying have like say you score
it and then also do the fight.
I'm saying maybe have him outside of it
because they have 17 commentators will
jump in there.
Big Guy though.
Now it's Goldie and big John.
Well,
yeah,
frank,
Mary of Chill Sonin you got to college,
but while the fights are happening with
the voice you're hearing on television
is big John,
there's no way he can do that.
In my opinion.
I don't feel like that would be a big
Jimmy Smith.
I'm not saying you can't do it.
Jimmy Smith used to do scoring in
between and it was good.
It was good.
Jimmy is very good at what's it going to
do now?
Oh,
I don't know,
man.
I I'm not happy.
I'm not.
I'm not happy that the UFC got rid of
him.
I think he's really good.
I get it.
I understand it.
They have a lot of other pieces on bad
terms are the terms I do not know.
I think they were cutting the money.
It was a financial thing.
You left.
He's still on good terms.
He,
but they offer them less money because
of these other dudes,
so he's like,
Oh,
I'm a doc is off,
see their dream job.
But they signed a one year contract.
Did you ask anybody why they let him go?
They want to use fighters so it wasn't a
fit.
They decided to fight.
See fighters,
UFC fighters.
You know what?
That's how the NFL is.
Yeah.
Nfl,
you know that the color commentator
tater is always a former chief Tony
Romo.
Tony Romo was the commentators.
He got back.
I already best he calls exactly what's
gonna happen before it even happens.
He goes,
all right,
this is,
people kind of dislike it.
I love it.
He goes,
this can be a run to the right.
Get ready and then that sure enough,
that's what they do.
He reads it before it all happens.
Then they even check,
he goes,
he's going to throw up a slant in the
top left higher.
That fucking dude and hire the Pluto
event at a store.
Last night they were talking to how
insane is comically album?
Best adjacent Teebo was saying it's best
commentator,
an office worker.
They commentate a,
he did the,
uh,
I think,
oh,
he did the,
uh,
Brady game,
the patient.
It's cheese.
That game.
I noticed about mma,
but fuck Daddy,
talk us through this.
By the way,
here.
Here's the,
he's going for it,
but why this is happening?
Well,
what's called this guy's name out too,
because we didn't give this guy's name
or what he was,
um,
to counter the take down.
He goes for Kamora and he just,
he rides that Kamora all the way to an
armbar and then he kind of swims with
the,
with the Camorra is still intact.
The arm pops and bill fucking beautiful.
Huh?
That's tight ass submission.
He looks strong.
Super Powerful.
Kamora it's kind of amazing,
amazing,
powerful,
bearded Camorra's aren't just for
Camorra's.
Camorra's are for back takes and for
straight armbar setups.
You know what I mean?
So,
um,
the traditional Komora is probably the
heart.
You know,
when you,
you take the army and you crank it
behind his back,
that's probably the hardest of the
three.
You know,
it's probably easier just to use the
Camorra grip to take the back or to turn
it into a spiderweb.
Armbar at Dell to me,
Mimi,
Adele Al-timimi Aka Chris Pratt,
friend
Chris France in there with them.
It's Chris Pratt,
a comedian.
No.
How [inaudible] he's the guy who
controls the philosopher,
raptors,
Bro.
Fucking guy from Jurassic Park.
Dude,
I don't watch tress.
Guardians of the galaxy is the Gal.
God,
I walked out of that as soon as I fuck a
little wood.
The animal thing.
What's,
what do they call it?
What is a big diesel voice?
Oh my God.
Oh dairy was Chris Pratt right there
with the guy the whole way.
What is happening now?
This is a little go overboard.
Nice Chris.
So intense.
I love you buddy.
But get
the fuck out of the picture of this.
Trying to make any sense and that shirt
is way too tight and that's coming from
a guy like me.
That's how I like to wear mine.
No,
you don't say no.
You don't.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Especially for my TV is a midriff.
Not only I,
I'm doing pushups before I get up there.
Well
I'm going to do some fucking some dips
on some chairs.
Um,
that's a beautiful arm bar though.
Let's hear Chris Pratt get on the mic
shadow.
We don't have to turn it up.
It's okay.
Cause I,
I I don't one.
Oh,
we should tell people what the time code
is.
Do we have a time code?
It was so quick at and then that took it
off around.
I took it off.
It will let you guys know the tours
idea.
Maybe they think,
well,
how about we,
we have the celebrities walk out with
these fighters.
I'll try anything,
bro.
They'll try porn because porn fighter
porn,
Isabella,
towards the mantra kind of blowing up
though,
right?
Fighters Bang each other.
They're doing well.
I mean it's just paramount.
No,
no,
no.
That's was a disaster.
They've done paper view.
It was a disaster.
He's Gracie won.
They made money on that.
They didn't think that was paper view,
was it?
These do.
Well,
I like the paramount's do well.
They get good ratings.
Am I wrong?
I think the hoists,
Gracie one was not paper view.
Tracy,
Ken shamrock.
That's not paper.
That wasn't [inaudible] in 1996 it was.
They can't do a paper.
Did you watch it?
I watch it,
but all I was excited.
I was excited.
I watch them all and I have a problem.
Chocolate,
Dell and Tito Ortiz did 25,000 buys.
No Way.
Dude,
that's so fucked up,
dude.
You could do 25,000 buys.
I could piss into this beer.
Can he get 25 five signs?
You could show a funny,
you do a seminar on flat earth and you'd
get 25
that's true.
A lot of dumb motherfuckers.
I mean it is.
It is fucking crazy that that's only got
25,000 sorry.
No,
the card was so poorly done.
So bad.
The undercard was so fucking terrible.
The production was awful.
Their anchos where ethically bad,
ethically fucking bed.
It was kind of a shit show to watch.
I enjoyed it because it was such a shit
show.
It was just a decent products.
Not as far as the Oscar de la Hoya.
I look like it's so bad,
dude.
If I look like a thumb does,
Jay Glazer was like a big toe.
Big Toe.
Her Dick head.
Yeah.
Almost shaved my head.
How much shaved my head?
Completely complete freedom,
man.
Dude,
I'm losing it.
I've read it all.
Eventually going to have to shed.
You know
guy here.
Calen needs to fucking let it go.
Let's be real.
His share is going well.
I showed up with a bald head promise.
Don't do that to me,
dude.
Yeah,
get here.
Get the same issue.
Counted hair,
hair transplant too,
so he's got a scar back there as well.
So like didn't tell the world.
That's
fucking Rad.
He's talked about it before.
I know.
I would never say it if he did know.
I'll tell you as the fest,
you know who has the best fucking hair
piece is a pivot.
That shit I had no idea.
Do you know he used to play Georgia
stands on Seinfeld because he had the
same fucking birds nest thing.
Well,
he had a bunch of surgeries I think.
Oh No.
That thing is dead meat up there.
It's fucking thing is sewn into a skull.
I have no idea.
How dare you.
This is live.
Oh,
why people are listening.
I'm just saying he has fucking,
it's got great.
No,
I'm saying good friends.
Good,
good fake hair.
Yes.
There's no prompt.
You know,
it's no issues.
I'll probably do the same shit.
You know
it's not the eighties though,
because in the eighties man,
if you had long hair and you were losing
your hair,
it was basically a death sentence.
Like
I had knew I had a senior,
no one can have a shaved head back then.
What was the only guy we allowed him to
shave his head because he could sing so
great.
We just said,
okay,
well he was also allowed dressing really
weird.
You know what,
this fucking biker leather shoes.
He dressed like a people in the gay
community just came out with the leather
and the motorcycles and all that shit
and all the kids,
all the kids thought that was heavy
metal.
So I wore all that shit and I always
thought in the back of my head,
I thought it was weird that gay people
were the same shit dudes too.
He must be a coincidence.
We've talked about that on the podcast
before that Rob Halford con to whole
group of people and addressing gay.
How bout,
how bout um,
freddy mercury was telling everybody he
was super gay,
was not trying to hide it from anybody,
but I thought,
oh,
he's just a rock star.
His style.
His band,
his name was queen,
but no one thought he was gay who just,
no one thought he was getting some
people,
but not the match.
Took a while.
Yeah.
If you watch the movie,
the documentary.
Yeah.
Everyone was like,
whoa.
Now we look back and I'm like,
he fucking joke.
Everybody.
Elton John.
Well forget all of them.
Have a rock.
She's the craziest one.
Liberace.
They were like liberace.
When are you going to find a nice woman
and settled on that?
I keep luck and I can't find them.
I think Freddie Mercury is a little,
but it was a little crazier than no
liberace problem.
Name of his band was queen.
It's true.
It's true,
but he's a Rockstar rockstar.
Liberace played a piano and came out and
no fucking gold royals Royce and had
fucking pigeons coming out of his
asshole and we're like,
no.
Even though our mall did we talk about
this with girls La,
why there's such a disproportionate
amount of gay singers?
No.
Why?
Because who's dude who's running the
music business?
A lot of gay dudes and who's going to
amaze me?
Is that true?
I don't know anything about that.
It's true.
It's no big deal.
Did you know that?
You didn't know that?
No.
I I know who's,
who's,
who's down to suck Dick.
Oh,
is that what quicker than a gay singer?
Wait a minute.
So you think the reason why there's so
many gay seniors,
they're the ones that you talked to the
decks
to make it to the top because there's
guys who are just the there isn't it
possible to just hold on,
but let me,
let me,
let me offer you an alternative
explanation straight.
Here's the Oct.
Hold on.
Here's the alternative explanation.
Gay People,
uh,
feel maligned.
They feel like they're left out.
They are sad because of this.
They live hard lives.
They maintain all of this emotion inside
of them and they want to express it some
way.
And so they figured out a way to sing
and to entertain.
And goddammit,
Jamie,
just me,
a picture behind the candelabra is the
best movie.
That's what I think.
I think,
you know they're bullied and you know
they're depressed and the people that
are the most like pushed out in society,
those are the ones who become comedians.
Those are the ones that become singers.
Those are the ones they become actors
even cause they ready shit.
I miss something.
And outlet gay Comedians,
there ain't that many gang of them.
It was a gang of it.
There's a couple now.
There's a gang of them.
There's a lot.
I know,
I know quite a few.
I'd say there's more gay actors or
singers sang for seniors names named
some few singers,
the four or five,
but we tapped our dad to three a rob
Halford still kickin.
Liberace died of everything too.
He had the full comprehensive running
around.
It's,
I don't know,
just everything.
Yeah,
right here.
That Dick and plan all the dude's Joey
Diaz used to have a fucking bit and we
played a little bit of it one time on
the podcast,
but it's not the best version of it,
of beyond the candelabra the fucking hbo
movie with Matt Damon.
I love that.
And Michael Douglas Dude had chuck.
Do you remember?
Joey Diaz has bit,
yeah,
I taught in San Jose.
Probably one of the best sets I've ever
seen him do.
A in San Jose.
He had that whole bit down San Jose
Improv.
Joey was,
he got crushed in monster,
but he's still a monster.
But I mean that bit was just so funny.
It's such a funny bit,
man.
To comb comrade.
What?
Wait.
Why are they showing you?
Well,
oh,
they're showing the UFC heavyweight
champion.
Oh,
your tour day boy.
Bellatore everyone champions on your
birthday.
Can't come on time.
Shop was shitting on your hair while you
were gone.
He was shitting on your hair.
I told you,
I told you he wanted to shave his and I
said,
no,
I told you,
you never know when there's a lot of
room here at.
He shaved your head,
Dude.
It's your bedtime.
You're on a microphone.
So come over here and sit down,
dude.
It's your don't make me fuck you up on
your birthday,
dude.
Okay Dude.
Have a seat.
Did you bring a wine and cheese?
No fucking cheese.
Did you bring your acts on your
birthday?
You didn't bring cheese.
No cheese,
dude.
Fuck Bro.
Jesus Christ.
We were just in the middle of like,
you hurt my ear.
I'm sorry.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What did he do?
Oh,
he collided.
You guys both collided.
Heads know that he shoved my earpiece in
my ear.
It it looked like he had a goal
to a gold team trip to Hawaii.
Oh,
that's my felony are here.
These are not good.
If somebody hits you in the side of that
mirror,
when I miss that
Shit Bro,
he looked good like,
here's good.
You get a little crew cut.
He should have weighed on shaving it.
Listen to these gummies losing it.
Yeah.
There's going to be a point where I'm
going to have to shave my phone.
Do you have a beautiful head of hair?
I said pictures.
I'm like,
God damn,
I got,
I got the biggest forehand.
Okay Dude,
I've got to get,
when I do my show,
they got to paint my scalp and he's
still got pain.
Puts him on his scouts.
Those one shave your head all.
I was saying is if anyone's gonna Shave
her head,
it's you because Eddie has good here.
Right.
So I mean if scale of one to 10 we're
going to lose your hair.
I get to about running in my eyebrows.
Yeah,
you might need hairline reduction
surgery.
I got the Rogan route.
You got beautiful shiny hair.
Imagine if that was a problem.
Like some dudes.
You know what I mean?
I know a couple of Brazilian guys rush
up their hair light right above the
eyebrow.
Like they might have to like shave in a
hairline.
Oh,
Khabib has to for sure.
His shit is very short forehead.
How about her Natto and not the mock?
No,
totally.
That guy,
his hip four,
it starts an inch above the cyber.
I love him.
He was my trajectory.
Great Guy,
great,
great guy.
Street bought up chest.
Couldn't be a nicer guy.
You know Jonah Hill is trained Jujitsu
with lag.
Jonah fucking hell.
He's pretty skinny and shit.
He's getting scared so much weight.
Got Skinny and then he felt like his
head was too big.
He started gaining weight back.
Now he's skinny again.
He's in great shape.
We realized that happens to people
sometimes because you know when you get
like 400 pounds,
your fucking head gets big.
I meant is that real and not touch it.
Taste when you're 20,
when you're role with somebody,
he'd go make his face nice clean,
beautiful.
Good for him man.
Because he looks good.
He does a good,
well,
you know,
if his head's bigger and his body's too
skinny,
just going to build your body up.
Let me get the sides of your head.
Boy Hills,
a very good actor.
He's a really nice guy.
He's a great guy.
I met him one night at one day rather it
k rock.
Yeah,
back when people did radio.
Oh,
there's Chen who just cub Swanson.
Jen Stevenson and then Jack Swagger.
Look at Cub Swanson.
Oh,
there's Joe Daddy.
So we are wa that's Joe Stevens.
So you just said that.
So we are watching the bell tour event.
Brian Cowen do you know is fighting
tonight.
Who is a door and who was he fighting?
Um,
Ryan Bader.
This guy's good.
Ricky Ben de Haas.
He's,
uh,
he's the guy that beat that.
Um,
that Irish kid.
The fuck's his name.
Gallagher.
Yes.
Yeah.
Gallagher's a motherfucker.
He k owed him.
He did bad and calorie to talk to all
that shit does.
He tried to,
he's basically trying to do the conor
mcgregor thing.
He is,
but he's,
he's talented.
He's very talented,
more talented on the ground for sure.
It's filthy and ricky's nasty standing
up.
He's got filthy.
She felt he in a good way.
And I like that expression.
I love it.
To stand up is filthy.
Filthy.
Well,
even when you're talking about girls,
like do,
she's filthy.
That's a good thing.
It's good.
I saw a hell captain went,
God damn,
that thing's filthy.
Yeah.
Well when you hear the girl was just
texting about something,
it's being filtered.
The other day I forget.
I just throw filter we thought around
and tossed around.
It gets a man's attention.
You're like,
Ooh,
she's a number.
She's,
she's a lawyer,
right?
Yeah.
And she's filthy.
Filthy does what a good kid.
My friend Jamie did tell you my buddy
from high school,
we would always say that we see a girl.
She was hot.
She will.
What?
A good kid or hot little mini skirt
fell out like what happened?
What happened last night with that girl?
She suck my Dick.
What a good.
Yeah,
it's a weird one.
What a good kid.
She's a good girl.
I'm like,
well that makes me feel weird,
dude.
Yeah,
real weird.
She's a good girl.
Good girl.
Say She.
She shit girl.
Creepy.
How much they hate acting now.
Now that you're acting to your picture,
I'll tell you what I love though.
Is you better like the people you work
with.
It's so fun to be around.
That's all I was doing a,
that was hilarious.
That's my new dance.
We should all do it together,
but take it seriously.
But doing a,
doing a like of doing a film where
you're,
you know,
doing that,
all the makeup you're in making the
three would do that.
They'll be,
if they call and you're like,
hey,
why don't you be that guy?
Look at me.
Look at me right now.
Dude.
Watch your fucking p's and q's.
You look at me.
Everyone in here knows you very well.
Him The other day,
you look at me 52 know what bullshit
they call and said,
hey,
we want to do a feature film and you can
be Robin.
Listen,
be.
Yeah.
You're going to be rocking it back.
No,
you're going to be a the Butler's name.
What's the Butler that takes care of
Bruce?
I bet you are older than Alfred was
show.
How old was John Candy when he died?
This phrase?
1,000.
How old was John Canning?
40 40 40 43 years old.
She was 700 Chris Farley's.
John Belushi started before these guys
died from drugs.
John Candy just died from obesity.
Right,
but they seem much older and now I'm 10
years old.
Kurt cobain 27 how about the 27 Kurtz?
Amy winehouse?
27 or excuse me,
Hendrix.
Jim Morrison,
27 Janice Joplin,
26 what's your point,
bro?
You're healthy.
52 I'm not going to die.
That's the point.
No,
you're not.
You're going to outlive me for
sure.
Wow.
Yeah.
I don't know.
What is this is Monday's.
While is this the wild whites of West
Virginia?
It's a tops baby.
Cops is still running strong and
killing.
It might be the most successful show in
the history of television.
That and simpsons.
Right.
I think cops might be more successful
now either remind the people that you're
not going to get away with shit.
They need to see the cause.
As you grow up thinking you never get
away with anything.
The cops,
that's not why it's successful.
It's successful because it costs zero
money.
Correct to zeal.
There's no actors.
A new main guys.
Sorry,
let her watch wwe wrestler Duke.
It was second in the nation and some of
the ways a hell of a wrestler.
He's fights to 35 usually.
I think this might be 35 an outstanding
fighter.
No Shit,
and I think he's undefeated.
Well,
this is a good fight them because
bandanas is a nasty striker.
He's putting you on your back no matter
what one our celebrity,
he's based one of the best wrestlers in
the country.
Two solid fights tonight.
Yeah,
super solid.
Yeah.
This is good.
You need to,
of course,
that's your sweet ass.
He's planning his toughest test and once
he,
if he,
I think he will,
if he beats this guy.
I bet you seem to be a title shot next.
Did you find out a one yet?
No.
Oh,
here's the thing about Pico to listen.
This Rogan,
I sat with a Freddie Roach.
I did an interview with Freddie Roach.
Comes out Monday for showtime period is
do this.
You got it back on it.
This is the gallagher knockout.
He caught that kick and he boom.
That's the name of the bed.
Not yet.
Yeah.
Well that's the beginning.
Yeah,
but he,
he,
that was,
that was his move.
That Irish kid who was,
yeah,
very kind of like flamboyant grill grate
on the grid.
Very good on the ground.
He's,
he just,
you know,
Irish and he loses.
The problem is he talked so much shit
when he gets fucked up like he did in
this fight.
So he gave me,
he was in the guy's face,
hands up in the air in this kid,
beat the shit
shit to the face,
Bang.
And he put him out here too.
Don't,
don't,
don't filthy.
Yeah.
And he screamed in his face.
Fall.
You,
I was saying is Freddie Roach said this
about Aaron Peko said he could be a
world champion right now in boxing.
If he goes,
I want him to do boxing.
I go,
why?
He goes,
he's one of the best I've seen.
And he goes for Miguel cotto camp when
he was a kid,
even younger,
like four or five years ago,
he would beat Miguel cotto and rounds.
He goes,
Miguel's not give him shit.
He'd beat him in round sparring.
He's so good.
He's just kid man.
He's very ferocious.
Was the number one high school wrestling
world lab with cal Lavita as well?
And Tj?
Yeah.
Teacher's main training.
Fuck it.
And when Freddy told me that when he
could,
he could compete in boxing,
it was compete.
He'd be world champion right now.
He was,
if he let me take them right now the
box,
it'd be a world champion.
But why doesn't he do that?
Because it isn't there.
Way more money in boxing.
No,
isn't there zero money in boxing?
Only certain times get paid.
Did the top besides pack Yap Floyd
Mayweather [inaudible] 90 too.
So that Loma chank was like,
dude,
yeah.
You want to do with the champ of who can
survive another generation?
Fuck.
There's no better than the boxing.
No,
no,
no.
This is true in the ghetto.
You just live in a nice community.
Correct.
The son of a bitch.
You got your Mexican privilege show
alive and well in Russia and Mexico.
They got some sponsors all the time,
Bro.
When are we getting hammered here?
One bottle at a time,
bro.
What are you an alcoholic?
Let it breathe.
One at a time.
Hey,
don't be snitching on an empty bottle of
90 or that I've got poured down the
sink.
Now we'll go through this.
It looks on this guy.
It's his birthday drink.
Miller light,
bro.
Like a God damn.
It's Eddie Bravo.
No one could ever accuse you of white
privilege.
They try.
They try 100% how can you show me 23 in
me?
Said what?
Bitch?
What'd your 23 and meets 100% Mexican.
Wow.
Is that true?
Oh Man,
I need to do it,
man.
Aw,
I did 51% southern Italian,
the rest,
uh,
western European and actually I got
Iberia and I got some North African,
I got 1.1% Asian.
Oh Shit.
I wonder if that is bullshit now.
At 1.1 just collected one a,
you know,
here's the thing.
It changes as the DNA testing gets
better,
you get different results in the mail
like every few months.
Like a I've found,
yeah,
I found out that I'm a little bit Greek.
There was no Greek in there before and
now it's showing a small amount of proof
of them just making shit up.
No,
no,
no.
They got no,
no,
no.
They told when the data base expands,
when the database with a genome expands
and they know the ancestry of these
different people,
it's very precise in the fact that it's
only like percentage points,
but it's,
they're pretty fucking act.
Did you guys all do the same one or is
it like drug testing in the UFC where
you sought to fund that and like I did
25 million,
but there's ancestry.
There's several different ones.
I did 23 and me too.
Two 23 yeah.
Yeah.
They told me I had my lote.
What my ear lobes look like?
How long my ring finger was weird shit.
I can tell you how big your Dick is.
Imagine that.
They can tell you
the truth.
Most of your Dick,
where are the charts?
Charts.
I need to get on these charts.
You've seen him at ease.
You'd never seen him.
10 Hug.
He's hey,
happy birthday brother knows this counts
be day.
Yes.
Happy Birthday.
29 to 60 70 years old.
35 to 52 area.
Here you go buddy.
Do you feel older?
Be Thank you so I don't get any drunk
cause becomes like a Gremlin when you
get water.
Go wrong.
I love any brown Thomas and he's a truly
good human beings.
I don't give a fuck and my friend
forever.
No,
we all love.
Yeah.
I like it here a little buzzed.
Jamie.
Fight up this flatter most ladder if the
k zero bro.
Dude,
how about mlk conspiracies though,
didn't mean to go down this road.
The Mike Baker Dude,
did you hear that?
I was humble.
I watched my bakers and then I went down
a rabbit hole on youtube on mlk.
Conspiracy from the CIA's convinced that
someone helped James Earl Ray to
convince guys legit as fuck.
So when he,
when he said,
all right,
let me look into that.
Here's the thing,
although I like Mike Baker's gray guy.
When when I brought up JFK,
he did the CIA killed jfk is like,
you know with Mlk,
Martin Luther King junior thing.
What about no,
but he calls him the bullet.
I'm like,
I know,
I know.
You see no,
let's hit things.
Lost credibility with that.
He goes,
yeah,
I do believe he was able to pull that
off and if you get up there,
you can actually pull that out.
Any hundred could do that were wrong.
No,
no,
no.
That's not exactly true.
You could do it.
It's not that far.
It's less than a hundred yards.
Dan,
you haven't.
It's a little shaky and the,
and the bullet,
the way the bullet came in telling you
the PR,
the only problem is the magic bullet
theory.
Okay,
here's the risk.
Here's the fight.
Here's a fight.
What is like a very thoughtful,
what does the gentleman in the white,
Arcola is that bald head and he's a
wrestler.
High levels 21 and one real pedigree and
I think Ben Day has Zia Saxxon got,
oh look at that.
Take down now once he's on you,
you're not getting them off.
Watch this.
Oh Geez.
Swam.
Brian.
Count dropping knowledge.
Well he was on warrior,
so I spent a lot of time with them on
sac.
Did he throw you around me?
There was a guy in the last few seen
really hard guy to throw around.
Dude.
Oh,
shut the fuck up.
Who's the guy who's the guy bought in
the last UFC fights?
Just like could be.
He's a baller.
He's got tattoos.
He's from the east coast.
Gillespies Gregor Gillespies just be
mother,
father.
He is all fucking go rainy.
Defeat that man.
He fought Khabib.
They have the exact same style.
He's a very good fighter,
man.
It'd be very,
very interested in talking about him and
Kevin Lien.
That's fine.
You had hit him up though.
Is Fishing?
He goes away.
He doesn't do interviews.
Shit.
He's fishing.
Doing a Shisha.
Yeah.
Grows his hair out and,
and shaves it right before the fight.
He's a savage.
Yeah.
I'd love that to me too.
He's a motherfucker is a beast.
It how about MVP versus Davey coming up
in Connecticut?
How dare you Scott.
Cause that fights in Connecticut.
Why not do that in England?
Everyone fucking loves those two in
England.
I don't know.
That doesn't make any sense.
The problem,
they knew that it's such a big fight.
You do it in England.
The time zones are all fucked up.
No,
the problem is the problem is riots.
Those fucking soccer hooligans.
They're going to go crazy brush this
time zone.
Look at this.
Watch
the UFC.
Some of the lowest rated.
It's true.
They kill it in England.
Like Joshua site.
They'll do well,
but it's just tagged your boy with a
right hand.
Not True.
Yes he did.
We just clipped him as he's trying to
close the disc confirmation bias.
I'm not,
how dare you?
I don't have no confirmation bias.
I'm not attached to this guy other than
the fact that he had friends on
instagram
and I
sent him once and there was a great
fight.
Oh,
nice.
Jumping front kick.
So they know him once and no matter
what,
I'm rooting.
I mean instagram friends with the mortal
technique now.
I love that too.
I'm like fanboying out.
He's a good guy,
man.
You never met him.
Never met.
Oh,
I'll introduce you next time he's in La.
I'll try to get a school portal
technique.
Who's that?
He's a rapper.
Bad mother fucker.
Very,
very good.
We're talking about doing a song.
What's his,
what's his real name?
What's his rap name?
Moral tests called memorial technique.
I've never conspiracy story rapper he
slept at,
oh,
let's tell everybody what time it is on
the clock.
It's 203-TWO-OH-TWO-201 to two minutes
and this is the first round.
If you want to sync it up,
but you probably can't drop in level.
Come on.
I liked that beard though.
Me To moving around like the waste
movement.
Oh,
he said he's going wild.
Like he's very kinetic.
Like he's,
he's,
he's making these big leaping movements
and he's doing it in the first round.
If he tries to shit in the second or
third,
like he's going to get tired.
The movements are slower and more
pronounced.
So start wrestling.
Yeah.
He's going to have to because he's not
that good at closing the distance with a
striking as striking as these big
movements.
See that these are these big movements
and had been day has
facebook.
I can time these big movements and
pause.
He's hurt.
He's hurt bad.
He got her,
he got hurt earlier to you.
I clipped with a right hand.
There's a takedown.
So Guillotine stuffed.
Stop.
Push that left hand off.
Tie or yeah.
You see that's what he's saying.
I know.
He's like,
he's losing his hair.
He's very,
he's already lost his hair,
but he's still in the fight.
Clipped him with the left hand there to
Ben.
Dance is no joke man.
Get Fred's guy
once I shaved is planning turtle right
now and he's just decline.
Right?
Like I said it,
I'm thinking about growing a beard.
Once I shaved my head,
fucking city.
Great head of hair.
Just crow.
Eddie.
Break it down to the hair thing,
man.
You got great hair.
Stop.
Let them shave it.
No,
the keep trying to get everybody on my
side.
Joe wants everybody to be hairless.
Hairless misery called.
Let me tell you something,
man.
This is why,
because I think people that take
propecia and stuff like,
I think you're fucking your body if I
take it.
I think that stuff's terrible.
I stopped like
he loves it.
Cause depression already already had
depression.
I no,
no,
no.
He did not.
He did not think it was just from
propecia.
Nice takedown.
Shut up to his feet and he was
exhausted.
Now he's an effort
to go.
Joe Benevidez did like two or three
times and his last fight sticks that
that is super legit.
Hendo does that a lot.
Yes,
that's Enzo did that in his last time.
I may fight.
God.
I'm sick of this
commercial.
Alicia,
that's not writing.
She just was same movie every time.
What's her name?
I forget something like Amy Schumer.
Nice be nice.
I am,
dude.
She's well,
no,
she's a good actress.
What's going on here?
She's filthy,
Bro.
Um,
what were you stocking but oh,
propecia and argo.
You don't think he,
you,
you don't think that he already kind of
had a touch of the dog?
No,
he didn't.
You think it was all you just shouldn't
chocolate.
I know.
It's one of the side effects.
One of the side effects of severe
depression from have peace.
You have really two d Brian's propecia.
Is It d h t inhibitor.
The reason why it works to keep your
body from losing his hair is because
dihydrotestosterone,
which is a derivative testosterone is
suppressed by propecia.
Propecia was originally proskauer and
proskauer was something they use for
people with a prostate enlargement.
So you get on that stuff.
It inhibits dht so your hair stops
falling out and grows back a little bit,
but it also fucks with your body,
your energy levels.
Dude for me,
this is what,
yes,
for me.
For me it wasn't very good for my
boners.
I still got them,
but this is what,
what happened?
I stopped taking it because I ran out of
it and I forgot to get a new
prescription.
How that goes in.
My Dick was hard.
It was just like this hen hunt and I was
like,
what is happening with my Dick?
And then I realized,
Oh my God,
I'm not on the appropriate [inaudible]
dude.
And I realized propecia was fucking up
my boners a cat could not,
it would blend.
I mean,
sorry,
keep going,
keep going right now and he can look.
So then I got off of it and the first
thing I noticed is how much more energy
I had.
Yes.
Like more energy,
like lifting.
I could lift more.
I had more energy to roll forever and
then obviously counts and my brother to
Jay's like fuck,
just fucking full set of hair now.
He was losing it and you got a back.
He was losing it.
Yeah.
And it's fair to shit and cause a huge
Dick.
He's got a kid has got his take ruined
my day.
It tastes like it's my brother.
I'm going to sneak in there.
I saw his face cream.
I mean,
shout out to Jay,
his dick.
Your voice hasn't fucked up,
right?
He's this time.
Although I am worried about the knee.
He's,
he's kind of,
he's,
he's leading with his chin.
Well,
no,
he's just,
he's coming in with his head and,
well,
he's tired because he's making these big
movements.
He has to make big moves to get him
because he's not a kicker and because
he's not a really good striker,
so he's far on the outside,
so he's got to close 1820 inches before
he makes his run.
But he got poked in the eye.
He got,
oh,
now he's really fucked.
Yeah,
he's fun one.
I callen tired.
Can't sand.
Oh,
that kick.
Oh No,
you've got to rap on it is why he's on
the outside.
He got ragdoll to the ground.
No,
that's not true.
They'll never throw that cake again.
That'll be in the back of his head for
the rest of his life.
Every time he throws that Bitch Ass Co.
Oh Dude.
He's just setting him art.
There you go.
What happened now joe would haven't
seen?
Do you know of this?
Time is going to get tired.
I take a shit in the first round.
He's tired.
It's time to take a seat.
Why would you want to bet on this fight?
Yeah,
I do.
Okay.
How much?
I'll bet you a $1 fucking million
dollars.
Wow.
You actually have $1 million now,
so that's interesting.
I do see how the Internet,
if you look at my,
my net worth,
it's I think it says I'm worth 200 grand
and has a picture of British show.
Interesting.
I really did for me too.
My,
my network.
It was a picture of Brendan Schaub was
one.
He's fun.
Well,
it said Brian and I were brothers or I'm
on Wikipedia for like 10 years ago.
Everybody would say that pauly shore
thought you would have brothers.
Everybody did.
Well,
it makes sense to that picture that
Brian post of you guys in the early
nineties hilarious dude.
You had some swag,
dude.
Good luck.
Rip Right Jamie.
I was like,
I did.
That's the first thing I noticed.
Look,
your bro gets fucking fashion,
by the way.
You guys both shiny clothes back then.
That was like 95 this is why you and I
get along.
He was a kid.
He was a good look at who's cutie pie
guys.
Girls liked him.
That shit,
that liberace front with the fucking
leather jacket.
Those biker jackets are still in.
I still have that jacket and I'm not
lying.
Fairly muscular.
You guys just got busted Gerkin no,
no.
Like just pull their dick out.
And by the way,
you had never smoked weed.
You had never done any drugs.
People are like,
oh,
well the cocaine now we didn't do,
I'd never done blah.
We had a little bit of booze or drug of
choice was,
was it Brian?
I was 20 I was editing.
I was 28 29 yeah.
We were like,
I think it was 27 they're doing,
yeah.
Yeah.
I was 27 you were 28 if I had a time,
if your boy just cracked my day,
I was with the right hands,
right dude,
don't ever,
I'm losing my dog.
He throws that bitch ass kick again.
He gets taken down.
That's just a dude.
He's just buttering them up.
Ooh,
Mitchell and riskier tonto because
someone needs to take that guy to duke.
Roufus his place.
Teach him how to throw a kick dude.
Belters John that back the the lights
again.
Huh?
You got Mitch,
your own killed.
10 is February 15th the next night's MVP
versus daily.
Hey,
it must be working.
Do you guys want to go to Phoenix to see
cain fight in Ghana?
You want to just fucking get on with.
Is that it's like s it's a Sunday.
It's a Sunday.
I could do it.
I'm thinking about just fucking flying
to Phoenix.
I never go to a live USC as a fan,
but I want to see cain versus in Ghana.
The arena though,
100%
going to snipe me out.
It was going to stab you owe
me.
The four of us is the go live.
We'll put fucking snapchat cameras on
our eyeglasses.
What?
What is the day?
It's a Sunday night.
It's the 17th.
We check every free coun.
Yep.
What'd you want to do?
I do it.
Take a private jet as long as it's not
this weekend.
Sounds like we're talking Eddie or fun
man.
Was that seems stressed about it.
Oh look at this boy.
Your boy got good.
Uh,
you're,
you're a DM buddy has got good takedown
beef.
Yes.
And it does cause he knew he was
fighting a wrestler Bro.
Oh,
blocked second round.
Two rounds in the book for the,
for [inaudible] they had to Francis
Keynesian epic fights an epic fight.
Not really.
How about this?
Not even at the most,
not even a little bit epic.
Here's why.
Why?
Because Mr and Ghana,
all due respect,
great athlete came to two.
Okay.
Once again,
Keynes had 150 surgeries.
How it goes.
He's 37 years old.
He a fake skull.
You want an how it goes.
Ready?
Okay.
Is it lowers can text him down and then
punches in the face until it's over.
I don't think so.
It might not to be like jds I think
can't get to a hundred I hate to agree
with Brian,
but
yeah,
agreed on anything.
It's true.
Guess that wrestling you went to knock
them out.
JDS Did.
Cain wins,
but I don't think he gets a single leg
and just take some,
Jesus
puts his head in his chest and his bank.
JDS for sure in Ghana is fucking
dangerous unless you,
unless you have cardio,
he's showing something to fight.
He didn't know what the fuck he was
doing.
He thought,
well the Steve Bay fight,
he thought he was going to win that
fight by Kao.
You thought it was just going to go out
there and Kale.
He did land good shots on curtis plates
and that second fight and curse plays a
good wrestler in Carlos too.
What would it be,
Mark Curtis plates in that second fight?
You got to remember he just fucked up.
Curtis bleeds.
I totally forgot about that and forgot
about it.
That's why I work for the FCA and you're
going to have a hard time getting in the
arena.
Hey guys,
there's a fight.
Might be funny to do a fight companion,
but all free travel.
I always travel so,
but I was thinking like if you're going
to be taking [inaudible] leaves
a party,
have a good time.
Oh,
goodbye.
We're all married.
No,
your boy is not going to take him down.
He hasn't taken them down yet.
This is the third round,
dude.
It's not happening.
He needs to let that go and learn how to
kick with that left.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
He's got a pummel under with that left
hand.
He's going to get it and when he gets
it,
he's gonna Circle off and we circles
off.
Your boy's going to be more tired.
I am a commentator,
Tj and yours looks like actor.
Oh your boy.
Got You.
Gotta Watch that knee.
The right hand and he's fucked up and he
was what?
His right leg.
Just do their archeletta was a wrestler.
He's fine.
Oh,
he's a no,
he's in a world of shit.
Wrestle the shit your boys.
And a lot of trouble,
dude.
Be Honest.
Be Honest,
be honest.
Want to,
nope.
Not even gonna.
I'm not as a turtle.
Tried something and bailed on it halfway
in better.
You know your boys losing the fight.
You know that.
We understand that.
He might have said,
oh,
look at it.
Wait a minute.
Oh,
I was going to be for,
he gets back to his feet.
That doesn't even count.
Djs right there.
T has given him Joe Daddy there talking
to him.
Yeah.
What are they saying as well as dark
corner of the house?
I'll text both of them.
Right?
You're saying you need to stop him?
Nope,
they're gone yet.
We got cub,
Swanson,
Tj dillashaw and Joe Daddy seems in his
on a corner the best efforts corner.
Pretty God damn good corner.
You boys aggressive.
I'll tell you that.
Hey,
it's not letting go.
No,
dude,
I told you I think Ben Davis is winning
though and days he's losing his land to
collect on a dollar at the end of this
fight.
Off a shot.
Look at this start capping.
Probably win the fight.
Joe.
Just from control.
That's controlling.
I'm sensing Idm,
this guy,
you guys are out of your mind.
It's my birthday.
I get what I want would be kind of fun
to do a flight companion that might be
better.
I think that is test and we never get to
really do them for big.
We don't have to go anywhere.
We don't get it fucked up.
Legit.
Once I quit the UFC,
like we should travel like one or two in
Vegas and do live companions
from money from,
well I don't know if they'll let me but
from like a dope fucking sweet.
Ooh,
but you want to be on the floor,
man.
I like your food truck thing.
It's pretty,
pretty good.
Thank you sir.
With better.
I got so hungry looking at those steak
and cheese,
a text.
I texted Brendan immediately.
They were so good dude.
And I'm doing a lobster roll one.
Ooh is a place called fuck.
I think it's Maine lobster.
They are not the best.
I had cousins,
cousins I've had that they are talent.
I bought you one.
Remember that Alicia's role,
the best lots role in the world.
Like,
it's like,
it's like $15 and then you don't care.
I don't give a fuck.
So good.
I buy four of them.
Brian,
you're worth $200,000 a quarter to a
celebrity net worth.
I know.
So what's that?
Oh,
come on.
Your boys getting fucked up.
Fucked up.
Snatches ankle disaster.
Watch this.
Just keep your hand up.
Look at him.
Toying with him.
Twine like a cat and a mouse.
It in their fucking your dms.
Me Nothing to,
you know what else we should do?
Campaign as for big ass box and flex to
yes,
like cheery to them too.
Siri wild or too,
whatever.
You're not working.
Lets you do one and my tv show guys.
Oh that'd be so much fun.
No,
we're not doing that.
You see broner versus packout and then
broner afterwards saying that he beat
that guy up.
Well we watched it in the back of my
taping.
What the fuck?
I watched the whole fight out.
Me Too.
Like what the fuck is wrong with him?
Do we beat the shit out of him?
No,
he just beat him.
What's that movie?
Oh,
you got it.
I downloaded it a long time ago.
Oh that roar,
that crazy movie with the fucking lions
man.
It's a guy who trained lines and did a
whole movie with real lions where they
wrestled him and shit and they had the
lions like played actors in the movie
that someone died.
Two people got fucked up making the
movie.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Well they're giant cats.
This is the movie of all time.
It's pretty bad movie.
But it's like super dangerous cause
they,
they taunted the lions to get them to do
shit and the scenes.
Why?
Exactly.
Yeah,
definitely.
During the making of that movie,
people actually died.
You boy got side kicked in the body.
You see that pride.
He was winning this cat.
What?
What did,
what are you talking about?
You Bro.
Whoa,
look at this.
That's it.
That's the third round or just a lot of
problems.
Although she's side,
that guy's a stud and his debut took
some harsh 21 and one is that his debut
though?
He's 21 and one night.
Probably his first fight bell towards
the big four.
What's he been fighting saying?
I don't know.
He wasn't fighting in bell to her for,
I think this is one of us.
What's he been fighting and Jamie,
I mean 21 and one get in there,
bro.
You see zero fighting the fourth,
fourth fight in bellator.
Goddammit private Ryan
trying to hype the guy throwing shit
out.
Just let me throw some stuff on the
wall.
You were friends with him.
He's my buddy.
One time
I did a bunch of episodes of kingdoms.
Anybody who wants to ski,
I'm thinking warrior.
Does anybody else want any of this
whiskey?
I don't do well in whiskey.
Think he turns it into whiskey and then
we'll come out.
I'll shit my pants.
What is our rating of this wine?
Is it just okay?
He's tried it.
Is it okay to mix it?
I'm more than happy with it.
Almost corked.
Yeah,
let's try the other bottle.
I'm not too happy with this.
Those fuckers.
This cost me to,
you know,
to be great with this cheese.
Be Cheese fucked up.
I got some old cheese in the fridge.
Pastors,
I forgot the cheese.
It's a little less attractive than old
cheese cheese.
Old Cheese actually holds.
If there is,
it'll be fine,
dude.
The fuck out of here?
My refrigerator,
she's sitting next to a block of elk.
I would fuck up
government cheese.
What the fuck was up with that school at
school?
They give you the real cheese.
Whoa.
Boom.
Government cheese.
Would you,
were you ever on food stamps?
They put in that cheese.
Well,
it's just shitty cheese.
They're like,
here,
I just want it back.
You ever on,
did you ever get food stamps when your
kid,
believe it or not,
my mom qualified for one month.
She made too much money.
She made like 200 bucks,
150 bucks a week,
but we did get it.
I'll never forget.
We got one for one month.
We got food stamps and we went to the
supermarket.
We went on to vons on,
on Bristol.
I'll never forget this because my mom
said get anything you fucking want
because she knew it was going to be her
last one.
So we just went straight to the cereal
aisle and generally my mom would get us
like toasty outs,
like a big sack because she knew if she
bought like cocoa pebbles of Shit will
be gone in like 15 minutes.
She would always get us like the worst
serial.
Just silicon last,
you know?
But that time
sheet,
what'd you get?
Lucky charms.
What do kids do before there was slew
capillary cookie crisp.
I honey cow.
My chef made me a mom.
Man Count.
Chocula.
All right.
Who won?
Let's say yes off course.
Dot.
Already you have a doll ready for me?
Yeah,
dude,
there's no shot.
Your boy one he got,
he got taken down over and over.
Not really.
He didn't get back up to his feet,
but I think he controlled enough.
You boy landed better shots there.
You win,
got damaged.
What was the score?
Do we know?
Does it matter?
Was like a hundred to zero.
Here's a dollar.
Here you go.
That's a better,
that's a better fucking dude.
Look at frank trigg was the ref.
Did you notice that?
No,
I try not to
dude,
and I don't want to do it though.
What were you going to do?
You get caught myself better.
I'm getting better.
Getting better at this.
Like a demon inside of me.
Blurted out.
17 if there's fight win streak dude.
That's awesome.
Wrestlers man was out 35 or 45 handsome
young feller.
That's a good question.
I think he's 45 I might be wrong though.
Yeah.
45 right?
Cause uh,
I don't know.
45 pretty sure.
It's hard to tell.
I'll tell you what though.
Your boy is game and hell of a fighter.
I'm a fighter.
You know what man,
if there's one school,
that nice head kick right there that he
ate.
If there's one skill that a fighter
should have for it is wrestling,
right?
It means God damn.
If you could dictate where the fight
takes place,
everything that is so giant,
they keep showing him getting lit up.
Brendan,
I know you're against stuck kicking to
the knee to the foot,
foot stomps or you just kind of,
it's just,
it's a bitch move.
I remember when guides,
if you don't like you to just be like,
come on.
What?
It's like a,
it's like bro Code.
You like,
what the fuck you doing?
Cisco?
We're stopping really feet.
We kind of bit stumps a foot.
What are you doing bro?
It's obviously not going to affect the
fight.
Just a bitch move.
It doesn't affect them.
Not really.
Can't feel it.
You're so amped up.
No.
Afterwards your foot,
your foot.
Fuck.
But during the fight like what are you
doing dude?
What do you think?
You could break a foot maybe if you're
fucking bigfoot Silva and he stomped.
Mark used to do that shit.
Yeah,
he was so hard.
I'm sure if you are a real bitch,
he could do it for real bitch ass bitch.
What if you broke someone's foot?
If we stomped down their foot and snap
their medicar.
Okay,
you went by foot stomp.
Congrats.
Wow.
Damn.
Yeah,
he knows a lot of time.
I know exactly what you're talking
about.
Fucking ever stomped feet when I fight.
Notice most people don't.
Most guys don't.
John Wick used it in the bath house
scene.
Ooh,
stomp the dude's footage shot on the
chest.
When is that going to happen?
That's for the title.
That's how quick fitch gets a shot at
the title.
Well it's cause it's the welterweight
tournament.
So anyway,
having fights.
Roy can kids a shot at the,
it's pretty dope.
Yeah.
He wrestled.
Fuck Paul daily and then he's
immediately getting a shot at the title.
That's a good site.
It is a shot.
Great.
Ross.
It is an interesting fight and
especially if I like it and beltre cause
they're a little more lenient in their
substance.
Oh,
don't get protection,
sir.
Yes sir.
Yes.
We trying to lenient.
Well,
Fitch said tested positive before.
No one gives a fuck about Roy McDonald.
How he works at Google right there.
Holy Fuck.
He works in a murdering department.
He's there.
Somebody like leaks out some trade
secrets.
I know you guys because it shows up at
your house.
Why the best I can imagine a pencil.
He shoves it through your forehead.
He looks like he's in shape and he
works.
He's the guy who plays the riddler and
got them.
Exactly.
He's the Canadian site.
Seen that exact day about worry.
As much as you see his glasses is preppy
shirts.
You look in his eyes and you go,
yeah,
I'm all set.
I'm all set with this done.
It's going to go over here.
I'm not,
I'm not going to argue with him about
that on the podcast a long time ago.
You,
you,
oh yeah.
Oh come on God.
That's good.
Good call.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Every angle.
It's not just certain angles.
That's crazy.
Look at him on TV and look at Rory.
Wow is crazy.
He hates this shit cause I told me
should go by Canadian psycho and he
didn't know that right there.
That's right.
That crazy
fish is a stud.
Fish is a fucking savage.
But been in the game.
A La dude heat loans at welterweight
dish argument and he's one of the top,
I mean,
top six.
And you look at it,
he didn't do is he looks like
he fucked him up.
John.
I mean a Hendrix.
Johny Hendricks fucked him up.
He's a very straight for a long time.
No doubt about it.
Animal Go Jake Hagar,
also known as Jack Swagger.
Y'All.
He beat Eric Silva when Eric's hill was
a not under the care of Usada.
How big is that guy?
He's he bending.
Is He,
is he not able to he to be.
He's taller than me.
He's probably,
they say six seven that's full shit guy.
He's six five and he wrestled at
Oklahoma and he became twila allison
one.
Over time they're getting him to fight a
guy who makes me ball subs for a living
meatballs,
so,
oh my God,
boy.
I liked that right hand
shoulder.
It's like the chicken and waffles.
Roscoe's in the background representing
dude,
that guy's about to get was the last
time he ate at Roscoe's doing a hot mic.
When I was in Vegas for fight week,
when Tony fought anthony,
they got this chicken and waffle place.
I forget what it's called,
but it's a chain.
Did I eat chicken and waffles every
fucking day?
It's delicious.
Calm.
Jesus Christ.
I forget the name of it,
but it's a change in good way to get
fat.
It's always in Dublin right now.
It was hilarious.
He was Haitian and did a whole thing up,
a series of posts for from a whiskey
place talking about,
great,
this whiskey is the best whiskey in
Ireland.
And people like he's throwing shade,
he's throwing shade.
Like how's he throwing shade?
They're paid him.
They paid him to go off and he's the
fucking featherweight champion of the
planet or star just because they paid
him,
but they paid them to go to Dublin.
Whoever made up
the whiskey company forum.
Jamison all to what?
A classic movies.
Classic move.
Proper checks.
Wow.
Yeah.
Oh,
champ.
Champ.
What?
And I'm a,
I'm a fan of proper whiskey,
however tried it.
I'm not a whiskey guy.
How should I try some buffalo trace
motherfuckers?
I don't know.
Good whisky that could be pissed.
Is that a good whiskey?
Oh,
it's very good.
I'll try it.
Yeah.
Hold up.
You ready for this?
This company was established in 1773
it's not an ad right now.
It isn't that,
oh,
it is at the beginning of the podcast
and that this is a legitimate
17 hundreds really?
Where's your fucking glass?
I don't have one.
Apparently.
Brian,
you scared.
No,
I understand what your birthday get
fucked up.
I got my wrap party later.
Wrap these nuts in your mouth.
Why and where did the wrap party?
This is the rock party.
My TV show.
I'll just have a sip of his.
I'll have a sip of Brian.
Do you don't want to
tell me what's up?
What's up?
Yeah.
That's beautiful.
That's a beautiful way.
It's real.
What does that call shit?
Buffalo Trace.
That's a beautiful no bullshit.
This shit.
This shit is really been around since
the 17 hundreds really isn't smooth.
When I say the oldest running whiskey in
the in the country,
oldest running distillery on the planet
as a smooth whiskey.
Bourbon whiskey as real shit.
I like Blanton's.
I like that.
I like Nikka coffee grain oof.
Little [inaudible] I don't like with
this is this.
I don't like whiskey and that is smooth
as fun.
Kara Melanin.
Beautiful earthy Carmel,
correct,
sir?
Earthy.
You got some earth and some caravans.
Where would people would they get with
wines?
It's gets tenants that her counselor
left there.
How about this Earth Chalk case?
I don't know what earth taste because
I'm with my buddy.
It's nice.
Made a lot of money,
a lot of money,
hold on conversations.
I got to my buddy and went by by made a
lot of money.
Whatever you think is a lot.
He made more when you go to the fault of
the way and we and the somebody is there
and he's looking at wines that are $700
something crazy.
So we're going to get a crazy wine,
drink beer,
eat a bunch of caviar.
And he goes,
uh,
and she said,
how would you describe this?
I'd never had this,
but I've had the sister wine and she
said,
it's like getting roundhouse kicked in
the face by a ballerina and I have the
chicks at this.
That's really how you're going to
describe this wine.
It tells me nothing.
Was it nice that makes me think you're
an asshole dude.
I don't have a dream.
This might be my fucking through
Ballerina roundhouse kicks me in the
face.
I'm like,
I'm hanging around with the wrong girl.
I hated the fucking on me.
I think he's filthy.
Kicked me in the face,
filthy,
filthy.
Go home.
TMZ.
You ever had a girl hit you plc?
I don't know if swing at me once back
when I was fighting and I saw her hand
come up and I saw her,
her shoulder go back and I saw her right
hand come my way and I'm like,
I don't believe this is even happening.
Doubling garbage.
I ducked under and I just grabbed her.
I had a girl reached out to the right
hand and grabbed her.
I even think about hitting her cause it
was so ridiculous.
I had to go reach down and grab a boot.
I said,
you're being dumb.
I didn't say you're just
trying to hit you.
Uh,
she didn't just try to hit me.
She reached down.
She goes,
I'm dumb.
She didn't say,
I said,
you're being done.
It's,
hey,
you're Tom.
She goes,
I'm dumb.
And I went and before I could get out,
she fucking,
she was athletic.
She reached down and grabbed my boot.
She grabbed my boot by the,
you know,
and,
and swung so hard.
And I remember I ducked.
I just saw it coming and I just went,
I ducked and it made a crashed into my
closet,
you know,
and just meant a huge hole was not just
what you do.
That's true,
sir.
That was the house.
Yes.
Brian's house.
He has no door knob.
Yup.
There's a whole,
he was pushed his door and I go,
Bro,
you don't have a door.
It's like,
ah,
I gotta get it fixed.
So one day I'll,
a homeless lady walked into his house
and started making breakfast.
I had two pit bulls too.
He was asleep.
Oh,
homeless lady was making breakfast in
his kitchen.
She's was like,
yeah,
I had a really nice house.
It was,
it wasn't sleep.
I came home and the neighbors were
freaking out.
They had called the costs come in and
she goes,
and I'm in there and she's making me a
whole meal.
And I came in and my dogs were there and
she's like,
honey,
you got it going on.
You got it going on the house.
And the cops came,
you want to,
I was like,
no,
it's fine.
I go,
thank you.
So [inaudible] called the cops though.
No door knob.
She was making me a full meal.
It was fantastic.
I was going to say two things,
not terrible really back then I was like
roll the dice.
I mean if you had a little less crack a
year before the crack epidemic,
maybe,
dude,
when I first started training the girls
I would date because I was training all
the time.
Whenever we get all you did hit me in
the face,
they'd always punched me or pushed me.
Cause you're so big,
I hate it.
They can get away with it.
Correct.
Because it's like hitting a punching
bag.
Not Cool.
Look,
it's going to come their way.
Correct.
And then I remember I was living in this
basement with all these roommates and me
and my girl at the time were fighting
and I was like lifting a lot of spite to
65 at the time.
And uh,
she did something that horrible.
I forget what,
but it pissed me off and there's a couch
and I wanted to leave.
And I remember I was like,
just fucking do it.
I lifted up the couch and to me,
I thought it was a heavy couch,
but it was like one of those Ikea
couches.
This thing went and fucking hit the
ceiling land on the wall.
And she's like,
oh my God.
Like oh shit,
it's fucking,
she got hot.
No,
she wanted to call the cops.
I'm like for throwing us so far,
I didn't mean to launch this Shitty Sofa
over throwing us sofa.
I don't think you can.
I don't think so.
If the cops came and you'd be like,
I didn't throw it,
don't have to arrest someone or if it's
a domestic violence call.
So even if it's not true,
they got to take me away.
Yeah.
But if it's not violence,
if the cops come hashtag no,
Greg Hardy.
But if the cops come and you say,
I didn't do anything violent to her,
I just got mad.
I threw the sofa over there.
Yeah.
But then crazy bitches go.
Doosh doosh doosh doosh doosh doosh I
know a guy did that with a girl.
He started clawing his own arms.
Yeah.
These kind of a pussy justice honor bit.
That's my joke where I talk about
sometimes you get so mad at to grow that
you want to kill yourself.
I don't think that's what happened.
I think he did that because he thought
that she was going to fucking do it to
him.
Oh,
she was gonna call the cops and like
they were screaming at each other and
they probably thought the neighbors
heard.
Yeah.
Why?
Like I'm gonna just fucking around.
He just started clawing themselves.
But I told you,
I told you this story.
I was breaking up with the girl.
I told her foot stumps.
You remember that story I told you that
I was breaking up with the girl.
She was moving out of my house.
She started opening my windows going
stop heading,
man.
Oh yeah.
And I was like closed in the winter.
You don't hit him.
Look at this fight they're setting.
Do you look at the genes?
He looks like the guy from Orange County
choppers.
He's going to find those genes just so
he can get dressed quick on the way out.
What?
I'm paste.
Yeah.
This is a cell.
Here's the fight.
Ready,
takedown,
grounded,
pound stoppage in a minute.
Quickly.
Yes.
Yeah.
This is a setup.
I don't like that.
What was that?
His debut?
It's a,
he's never fought before,
so having fight in a smaller
organization and not just feed them to
these fucking,
he shouldn't be,
he shouldn't be in jeans.
It's not disrespectful to him and it's
not disrespectful to the sport,
but it's disrespectful to a large scale
organization to have a guy who's a guy
who's coming in from pro wrestling's,
got a big fan base,
do it the right way and then eventually
make your way into a big organization.
What are you talking about?
He's like homemade event on espn.
Well,
how'd that go?
How'd that work?
Awful.
We watch it together.
It was a joke.
Why knew that guy was,
uh,
was fading quick.
We were talking about it and your green
room.
I was like,
he's fading.
I don't like the way he's stepping.
He looks exhausted.
He tired out quick and then he hit that
too.
With the illegal knee.
Do you think he's still going to be in
the UFC after that?
100% they've invested too much in I'm
Dana said he's,
and you have another fight.
Wow.
Interesting interest.
It's a bummer.
But that's the life we live.
And what do you do with them?
What I do with them,
I did give him Derek Lewis and give him
the fuck out and I go,
oh,
he liked to hit women Lewis who came
from a domestic violence home.
Yeah,
he's pretty good.
Enjoy this.
I want to be a fighter.
Here's Lewis,
Derek,
but too,
now I know he asked mad how many fights
is greg hardy had was as,
that'd be his fourth.
He had three on the whatever and white
guy like that.
It was a pro bowler.
Really Athletic.
Wouldn't his learning curve be very,
very steep?
I would.
Oh quick,
wouldn't he?
Wouldn't he?
He he just too much.
There's too much.
There's too much to download.
Especially at his age.
He's 30 so you got to download a lot of
information.
So maybe he's working a lot on striking,
but you can't cover Jiu Jitsu,
kickboxing,
wrestling,
bottom at all.
No matter who you are now it doesn't
matter you to take Herschel Walker.
It doesn't matter if they're that great
of an athlete.
It takes a fucking wild to learn the
skill.
Well,
Herschel Walker was a world class
athlete and a lifelong martial artists,
different animals,
different,
but I'm saying even if you take an
athletic like Lebron James would
struggle,
did you throw it to the UFC?
Firmly believed that Hershel Walker
would have given a lot of dudes a hard
fucking time at his age or if you
started early in his forties even his
forties I think he was such a fucking
freak stud of an athlete.
He's such an outlier.
I'm going to give it a lot of speed.
Heading to 35 he was running,
he was running Olympic speed.
He's in the Olympics.
He was such a freak.
It's just unbelievable and a real
martial artist,
but you really had skills.
Like when,
when I first saw him fight in the UFC I
was like,
or it strikeforce rather.
I was like,
oh my God.
Like he can actually fight.
Like dudes are scared of him.
Like he was.
He was moving in the right way.
It wasn't doing anything wrong.
Who's taking guys down?
Smashing them.
And the physical power that he had was
just scares body.
So stupid.
Ridiculous.
And also the team he trained with AK,
he was ready,
he did it the right place and they gave
him the right fights.
It was good.
Yeah.
But if you started younger,
you dove real prominent hands,
real problems.
If you wanted to be an actual,
it's interesting because you know when
you get like elite athletes,
how many of them actually want to fight?
Who's the most elite athlete in the UFC?
I think Yoel Romero?
Yes,
100% and he's a wrestler.
Cuba.
It's either boxing or wrestling.
Remember ul Romero is a freak and so
amazing because he came to mma at what?
35 30 Oh,
with the Astros and to be 62 years old,
walking on the beach with a Dick,
like a fucking quicker oats box.
Hey,
between his leg direct dude,
he's fighting fucking homeboy.
The other dining.
Yes.
Paul Acosta.
Eddie Bravo.
That's fucking tweet that day.
What did he say?
He just said it to us,
but it's a lesson of some private shit.
I didn't make that,
but until we got a little grin to Jamie
right now.
It's fucking great.
Who is this guy?
You can ever take that JW Kaiser.
I don't do means he,
some guy's about to get fucked up.
I don't need to download his information
coming up.
Jack Swagger's the guy should probably
take notice.
Okay.
I'm not,
I'm not mad at the bell.
Two are girls not mad at all.
Dude.
Mercies mattered at all.
My wow.
Paula Costa and Yoel Romero for sure
have the best board.
100% 100%
pound.
Yeah,
but Luke rockhold is longer and thinner.
He's beautiful model.
Beautiful.
But there's a big difference.
He doesn't want to be a gorilla.
Look at this.
Yo Mirror was,
Eddie said that just today we're fucking
house.
How
he sent it,
not make that didn't make it.
I agree with it.
I sent it to the UFC
prior to agree with it.
I don't even want to know what to say
right now.
Let me say that Shit.
You stay up the,
I'm trying to get fired.
They call me in this week to do fucking
the breakdowns.
Shit.
Fight breakdowns.
I think you shouted test two more.
I think it just got a bell toward tattoo
on his back.
Oh shit he does.
It's like slash bell towards slash
Caribbean slash 300 movies slash
[inaudible] has health.
Imagine if a guy had all giant depths
tattoos.
That'd be sick.
Now the other guy's a pro wrestler.
I don't know anything about them.
Yeah,
in Wf for lunch,
you can go ask.
Is anyone want to bet?
Bet 10 bucks.
I bet you a dollar that I lost on Brian.
The 20 bucks.
20 bucks.
All right.
Did I take that dollar actually took it
didn't.
Nice.
Nice Eddie.
It's such as I knew the guy that doesn't
think cm punk should have gotten a shot
and now you're,
you're,
you're favoring.
Whoa.
Wrestling won't see.
That's the problem.
Maybe cm punk doesn't have any amateur
background.
This dude be Cain Velasquez twice in
college.
Oh,
he's a wrestler who?
Shit,
I take it out.
I don't want to take your money.
Take Your Jack Swagger beat Cain
Velasquez in college.
Rissa Oklahoma had offers from Oklahoma
state.
Everyone.
And what does go to Oklahoma?
Real name?
Jack Hagar.
Swagger's a good name.
Hey,
this is guy.
Handsome guy.
Great Dude.
Really good dudes.
17 pretty humble.
What does e six seven taller than you?
It's just this tall.
He's not six seven.
What is this?
It this birthday.
That's uh,
it's a vitamins.
[inaudible]
you have a test that sucks,
right?
You have a tesla.
You got one here,
Bro.
I be cool.
You'd be so much fun or on the set of
whatever the fuck you're doing.
Must took a hit.
I just want to be friends with you guys.
Come on.
Just don't inhale.
Do it bro.
It's your birthday.
Birthday.
Like you guys your killer Mike.
Yeah.
Killer Mike.
Dude.
Come on Bro.
That's good.
I don't want you getting crazy.
Does Noah,
is it tobacco,
cheech and Chong here.
There you go.
Let me see.
Let me say blow it out.
It's his birthday.
I can't smoke weed,
man.
Dude.
No one's got your birth the case.
Not your birthday.
Fuck it.
I'm only on wine.
Oh Shit.
Look at this.
Who is this?
Turn this up.
I want to hear him.
It looks like it is.
It's always a whose notes?
OSP.
What?
He's got nice pants and shoes.
Prue is rapping now.
Check the pants and the shoes.
I think you might be doing.
We the people.
All my dad is you.
Well that's his walkout song.
Oh Wow.
Lucky.
What do you think about the pants and
the shoes,
brandon?
Uh,
I'm not,
I like the red jeans about,
I don't like the white shoes with Eddie.
Let me ask you this.
Do you ever to fashion or are you just
like me?
You know what?
If I was single,
I'd be all up in fashion.
I've been hanging out with Brendan.
Dude,
you liked fashion in the day.
Back in the day when you're talking
about that vintage Modo jacket,
you saw how bad my style was.
You just,
what I would wear,
I would wear like bowling shirts that
were very flashy.
I would find them and they were shining
or wear them on stage.
We're probably headed to a show.
Brian and I were probably our way out to
a show.
You have any idea where we were going
and that photo,
but we were 12 I know exactly where we
were.
Where were we going there?
You had performed at the Gox in a comedy
club.
Oh,
we ran out of your facility,
dude.
Big Ones.
And you crushed and we were with Patty
Jenkins in fact.
And you crushed the room.
I remember you crushed it.
And then we,
I'm going to be honest with my friend
Maria.
What do you mean you weren't used to use
to crush room?
What you oh it in 90 I remember him at
98 99 he would do fucking,
you would crush rooms.
I still have.
They still play my sense on serious.
I've never seen anybody who maybe never
seen anybody crush room the way you,
when you would do that shit when you
were younger.
It was nuts.
You'd come off completely drenched in
sweat.
The one,
I'll look it up.
Shout out to baby slice.
Kimbo slice his son.
Is that true?
Yeah,
Bro.
His name's baby slide man.
Fuck Dude.
I don't know.
Shit.
I gotta go.
No,
you don't wrap out parties.
End.
I got to go to it doesn't start til you
get there.
Yeah.
When is the party end men,
but it's your show,
right?
Yeah.
Sorry,
I got to,
it's already seven.
What time does it start?
It starts at seven but I mean I got
time.
Oh Dude.
Yeah,
and that heard a couple of hours.
Wait for the food to get out,
bro.
Bro.
Imagine if you get there and there's no
one there.
If you go there now you're going to be
met with the extras who have scripts for
you.
Yeah.
Hey Brian,
I want to talk to you about this
independent film.
Dude,
let me on your podcast podcast.
Do you have it?
People tried to get on your podcast,
don't want on your podcast.
What do you do?
Oh,
that we had some issues and we blame
each other.
I go,
you got to talk to Brian to read books.
All of it.
That's what Brian Blades,
migos yet tuck shop.
He books it.
I just say this.
I say the truth.
I say we have sponsors and there's that.
They don't let you called them.
They sent her about it.
We hear about it from our sponsors and
also Brendan doesn't like you.
I say those things.
So your homeboys 36 hagers 36 he
wrestled for 12 years out of collect
cow.
He's going with his real name.
He wrestled.
He has to like,
you know the rock can't go as the rocky
movies anymore.
Otherwise wwe gets a percentage of it
because they own the name the rock.
Yeah.
Oh,
so he's a legit professional wrestler as
in wwe for 12 years.
But before that,
Russell,
that Oklahoma like legit restaurant,
oh,
I ain't got to hold up.
First of all,
this muscle of athlete,
he is got a scholarship to play football
at Oklahoma.
And then when I was like,
Eh,
I don't know about this,
when and when it did wrestling instead
cheese freak freak.
Oklahoma's as big as they get.
He was at the same time I was there and
they were gone.
Was he a walk on a I'm not.
I think they gave him a scholarship.
I think it was all,
yeah,
he's a monster.
So the wrestle in high school as well.
This guy looks,
I'm sorry.
I'll do respect that guy.
Looks like a regular guy.
Does he sells cheese stick?
He sells tires.
Is that true?
Yes.
Discount tires.
All right,
well,
so this is his first.
If there's a guy's listening at one
point in his life,
no disrespect bro.
No,
no tires are fucking tongue.
He's in there.
He might win by knockout.
He's in.
He's in there.
You've got to respect that.
Imagine if that tire salesman just
fucking hits it with a hammer.
It's Tony Buck got himself in there.
Yeah,
he's a professional fighters.
It'll beat the shit out of me.
I could.
Mike Beltrani beat him up.
Yes.
Well Mike beltron would kill him with
his mustache.
He's got that shit ready cause a mother
fuckers slips.
He's a good man.
Mike Bell trend is a brown belt in
Jujitsu.
He's a little cheer for you to also one
of the best reps and legit person.
Really good guy.
Super Smart.
He always gives you a real warm hug and
he's a very,
very good referee.
And his beer,
I like olives.
I say top three referee in the planet
and stuff.
100% a great guy.
You know there's a few,
well I want to,
I don't know.
I don't even want to put them in order
because I have to.
Here's one.
It doesn't get enough love.
Josh Rosenthal.
Oh boy.
Well guess what was the wrestling?
Rosenthal don't get left cause he was
gone for eight years.
No,
no,
no.
He wasn't gone.
He went away for,
no,
I don't even think it was three.
He went away.
He got six years,
right?
I think I dunno over some shit that he,
he wouldn't get thrown in jail.
La.
I love Josh.
He's cost,
but I'm just saying he went away for a
hot minute there.
There was also,
I think you have guns and it's not just
pot.
You get caught with guns and even if you
have the guns legally,
I think there's a lot of sugar.
What are your boy,
your boy swaggers about to submit him
while he's in half guard.
The power,
the Bron Waterman.
Fucking can we go with that?
With the old UK law.
You can win a camera from half cluck.
You definitely can get up there.
He's got it.
He just needs to sit back.
Yeah.
Well don't do the straight arm.
He's not sure how to do it though,
is he?
No,
he does.
He's treading the powers we do.
Matt.
Matt Hughes taps.
I always do this straight.
More from half guard drill rigs.
Matt Hughes Tap Joe rigs with the
Camorra from half court.
Oh,
that was a big elbow that just missed.
Had an arm.
Get that head and arm once wrestlers
like a real wrestler gets a hold of you
like a Matt Hughes or this character.
Oh Jesus.
Shit.
Gorillas.
Gorilla stole Bo's.
You know who's one of the strongest
people I've ever football.
NFL,
UFC.
Bobby Lashley.
Oh Geez.
That mother fucker is Hashtag no racist.
Go real strong.
Fucking belly will squeeze your Dick
off.
He's so iteration for him.
Such a good wrestler.
Yeah,
so jacked.
I mean he might like have like the most
moms,
she's going to smash these,
push it up.
He's still trapped in habits over it.
Depends on how tough this guy is.
It doesn't matter.
I don't know man.
Oh,
same that he brought actually jagger
baby.
Congrats.
That's why any proper teaches you just
to look at them.
It looks good man.
Well now,
but huge guy make guy.
He's Christ and a competitor.
Yeah,
I mean he has some work to do obviously,
but he looks great for sure.
He does.
And he's,
he got on the mic and rip a great promo.
Yeah,
that's what he does.
He doubt.
Let's hear the Promo.
We'll definitely hit the program.
He's a heel so you know he's going to
listen and that guy's fucking tough.
That guy fought that guy.
He mean he got it out for as long as you
can.
Don't look at me.
What I'm saying.
I get bread in soft Claire.
He said,
Brett is giving you the soft,
that's what we call that.
The software might not be the most
skillful and he definitely couldn't
handle this huge top flight.
Probably didn't button,
probably doesn't belong in there with a
guy that athletic and strong.
And Brandon,
let me ask you this.
How many guys you know that have fucked
up?
Chipped up elbows.
That's a super common thing right here.
Ships floating around in heel,
bone chips and shit and I was in a big
elbow guy,
just life.
Did you ever see that picture of
[inaudible] Jack Harry went to the
hospital and get bone chips.
He has no fucking,
it was like no.
Like you know they took a table.
They put like a little cup of nuts on
your table when you go to a nice
restaurant.
That's where when you're on the
airplane,
Macadamia nuts.
That's what it looked like.
Airplane here.
Airplane that they dropped the nuts off.
That's what it looked was in his elbow.
Why put just macadamia?
That's it right there.
Oh No.
That's all the shift from [inaudible]
elbow.
What the fuck?
Yeah Bro.
Listen when you just won't tap like Jack
Ira.
Did you ever see that was it?
It wasn't Abu Dhabi.
What was it?
Was it the moon?
Dealz when he got arm barred by Hodgkin
and he wouldn't tap and hard.
You're broke his arm and he tucked his
arm and his jacket and wanted decision
rice.
Do you remember that?
God Elba.
Elbows tucked his arm.
Was it hot?
You're tucked his arm again.
Oh,
I'm wrong.
Yeah.
Who tapped him though wasn't it wasn't
joc array was it?
No,
it was it a Boucher.
You have a role with Patricia will
somebody did Jacques Arrayed though?
I feel like [inaudible] got his arm
broken.
He would not tap and he wound up winning
the fight.
I know
Roger with what happened with Vinnie
Maga last and Fabi silver doom.
That's true.
That happened to families who had a big
shocker.
Rey's arm.
Yes.
Thank you Jesus Christ.
I'll never question my fucking Koofie
memory.
That memory.
That makes no sense to draw.
So tuck this away too when aren't fully
snapped and just would not fucking
shocker,
right?
By the way.
Well,
how could this hodges hodges breaking
his arm?
How the best Andrea,
he almost tapped there.
It looks like you almost tapped.
So he gets out and when he gets out of
his arm,
his fucks Ville so they stay in the back
up again.
Now watch when he's standing back up
again.
He realizes his arm is fucked and so he
can't use it.
So check this.
He talks it in his fucking belt,
dude.
What a tough Savic wouldn't tap one.
The decision to chuck race such an
animal animal,
but today it gives them a fight.
I think JOC rates fighting soon.
I think he's got a good fight.
The good fight,
right?
Who is it?
Who is?
Oh,
Jesus said he's going to just,
you might as well.
I'm not drinking this.
Okay.
Who is my birthday man?
Can't have a couple of glasses of wine
to talk conspiracy with the fuck is this
chem trails.
It is his birthday.
I'll fuck.
He already believes that the moon
landing is real.
So it is a good point that,
yeah,
we did it.
I just want to tell you a little
conservative with the mlk thing.
You,
what do you think of that be?
Cause you're kind of a government and a
half.
The Mike Baker,
I liked Mike Baker.
I didn't hear anything about that.
That's later.
It's towards the end.
And I was one of the last things I
wanted to ask him in the last half hour
of the show.
There's a lot of youtube videos on that
by the way.
Ellen Mlk,
I went down that ramp.
Hold on.
That being a um,
you know,
conspiracy theory it,
that's,
that's just one of the conspiracy theory
I think most like there's the John
Lennon one too,
but just mlk for sure.
He was disrupting this.
Uh,
he was bringing people together in a way
that could disrupt power masses,
different body types.
This is a before and after
went to was just a shill.
There's one of those where they,
there's pictures of him and the
rothschilds and the rockerfeller's were
hanging out.
He said he used to have parties and fuck
just white girls.
But I would too if I was him.
That's the way it is when it really
counts.
But that conspiracy theory for sure,
he probably met those people cause they
for sure they probably wanted to meet
him.
It's not like you're either in or you're
out with a group like that.
Right.
Those two pictures.
I mentioned youtube videos on mls.
Given the Promo being,
um,
let me hear this.
Let me hear this.
See screaming.
What did he say?
Something that Oklahoma stand up but
there's no one in their threaten la,
so it's tough.
Oklahoma stand up.
You got like two dudes in the audience
and the lion and lion that they're from
Oklahoma.
We need oxygen.
Drove through.
Once I drove through one
big John McCarthy
drives that elbow is what's set
everything up for you to hit it with a
huge strike.
What were you thinking when you were on
the ground with them?
I was trying to slow everything down in
my mind.
Keeping me
sure.
Good answers.
Trying to slow everything down his mind.
I know going to get that big elbow in
there.
It's just a matter of,
you know what a guy like this,
you almost wishing he got in a 10 years
ago.
You know,
he can do some work at bellator
heavyweight though.
He probably when the whole thing,
if he can figure out a way to not get
hit,
you know,
he's huge dry and viking.
What does he weigh?
Dude,
I'm high as fuck.
I was looking at two 45.
How should I listen to 45 I think they
said it.
I used to 40 something.
He's a big fuck.
Yeah Dude.
Do you think there's a point of uh,
like where you're too big,
do you think like for some people think
to 65 is like too big,
too big,
really to 40.
Look at lead all the champions bay to 40
came to 40 jds two 40 to 45 pens on how
you fade or two 30
you could be 300 pounds.
If you say guys,
you can't talk over each other to mom
bro,
you have to be 300 pounds and athletic
and tr.
The problem is,
in my opinion,
as far as a Jujitsu goes,
the bigger the guy,
the less training partners,
the has to really get real roles and so
they end up like not really training.
Right,
right.
And that's why generally speaking,
the bigger the guy in Jiu Jitsu,
the last technique he has,
because he's used to roll in day after
day just using his weight and his power.
It's not his fault.
You know what I mean?
But if you get,
if you got to do this 285 pounds and
somehow he had like a billion
billionaire backer and he just got all
these big guys like every day he had
1520 big eyes.
The role with the old thoughts,
that's an example of Bouchet is a big
motherfucker and he super technical,
super technical moves like a cat.
So um,
it just,
it's just the bigger the guy,
the,
the Shittier the training.
Nobody wants to roll with the big dudes
to put together a super camp.
Big,
big guys come through and they quit
Jujitsu often because no one will roll
with them.
I think that's a big reason why DC's as
good as he is in cains,
as good as he is hunter,
those two fucking superhero smashing
into each other every day.
Fuck yes you are correct sir.
I called,
told me that,
that when Kane was healthy without
question,
baddest guy on the planet and gave all
of them,
all of them there,
he was a nightmare for all to dc.
Said CDC says healthy.
He goes,
brother beats off of them and this is
off my everything.
He goes,
dude,
I'm telling you what,
we've never seen anything like healthy
cane would,
can't fuck with them.
No
one DC DC said to me that he goes,
if that guy was healthy,
he goes,
I really watched Kane and I trained with
Cain and I can't beat that dude.
He said,
I can't beat that guy,
and DC was saying it just with a hundred
percent humility and just saying,
look,
the guy was the best meat death wish.
I wish there was a way to find out who
really was the best.
The most accomplished is steep bay and
he doesn't get into the picture a
dolphin.
It's not his fault.
Oh,
air pecos fight next fuck ass because
with Steve Pay,
Steve Pay Look,
he did what he had to do.
He won the title,
but the guys that he fought in that time
period would not the best of the best.
It wasn't like he fought cain when cain
fought jds to like fucking fight and was
prime.
Jade jds was a motherfucker,
motherfucker,
but also the argument to that to favor
and went undefeated for what,
seven years?
That is a good argument Mr Pico.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Like they did all the Pico,
so yeah,
everything be everything and he went on
to feed.
They don't know what fade door did,
but we know that they definitely let
people do things.
So whether or not he did anything or
didn't do anything,
it's just purely speculation.
I leave that up to you.
I mean I bet my life on it but not a big
deal.
But some people over there were
definitely doing stuff and they were
encouraging all this stuff and we know
people that went over there where they
encourage these people to take stuff.
So whether he did or was undefeated for
stats was that take everything aside,
leave all that co would fade or has that
none of them have is that motherfucker
will catch armbars off his back like a
lightweight.
Yup.
That's the one thing that separates him
from everybody.
Hey,
people would throw him through the air,
he would hit the ground and five seconds
later he'd have you in something.
But also his,
his technique was so unconventional.
It's not,
you can't train that.
Like with his hands down at his hips and
shit.
It's time winging punches at you.
He could take a shot.
I mean the Fujita fight memory went on
rubbery legs.
He got fucking rock.
Matt.
Not to mention the biggest thing,
dude had dad bod during all it.
All of it didn't give a fuck run to the
mountains with fucking trees.
All the gun drawing weird shit on the
side.
Oh here's something bout fade or the
people told me,
you know his favorite restaurant.
What?
Red lobster.
That motherfucker loves red lobster.
No,
it's,
you know his favorite clothing store.
What?
Abercrombie and Fitch.
Well it smells good in there.
What's up now?
The whole town
red lobster motherfucker can't get
enough.
The shrimp Scampi I guess.
I guess if you're from another country,
you don't know any better will you don't
think so.
I was like Brah displaces all.
I'm just not bad.
Like if we were all on the road,
if we were in Kentucky and we're just
driving through some weird fucking
trucks to and there's a red stop.
Red Lobster,
red lobster.
It's pretty tasty.
Crab legs.
Fuck up lobster boil it.
Too much water and lots.
It's expensive in Russia.
Absolutely not the shit.
But I didn't.
Exotic cuisine.
Gangsters get it.
We get
a hard to get.
Is it really expensive
or it gets up there in the dark
dark.
See there's got to be lobster,
blacks,
blacks.
Where?
Where I will officers to know.
No,
you sure
cause there's so much salt.
Salt lakes can show some organisms.
Correct.
Salt Lake in Utah,
some organisms,
I don't know.
I don't think it has fish nuts and fade
arcade and salt flats public.
It's salt lake city's try.
It's actually bryce.
Yeah,
but there is a lot of water there and
Salt Lake.
Can you imagine if you ever fly over it
when you go do wise guys,
you have to do that.
You do wiseguy parents retired and
it's the greatest,
greatest clubs the wise guys.
I'll be there.
March one and two.
I love seat and the owners.
My favorite owner out of all the clubs
keeps Keith.
Keith.
Keith is a great guy.
Last time he was there,
I was hanging out talking to them after
the show or the staff's all super cool.
No sports like a motherfucker rather was
an offense coordinator at Alabama Lake.
Great.
Salt Lake is too céline to support fish
and most of the aquatic species,
several types of algae live in the lake.
Okay.
Brian Chain shrimp and Brian flies can
also tolerate the hostess keys though
Brian Trippe eggs are harvested
commercially and are sold overseas is
prawn food.
Okay.
Damn Dude.
Can you imagine fate or comes here and
meets some hot girl and takes it a red
lobster and Abercrombie and Fitch.
She's like,
what are the goat goat took me to read
Joe's goofy sweater of honor on that
sweater.
A victory,
but he thinks it's just a ball or move.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but bulletproof cars pull up to drop
them off there.
You're still eating.
Should get to these bulletproof
suburbans with solid rubber wheels and
shit and arm.
He just smells like fucking Cologne from
Ab return car.
Smells like your car.
This Craig Glazer,
did he play football?
Laser,
laser?
Did he play football or train MMA or
anything?
But he's a colored tricky standing.
I think he is a coach
sometimes people because they can,
well it's,
yeah.
Yeah.
Josh and frank twig.
Oh Shit.
Pico as a prospect and over again dude.
Oof.
Look at that shit.
He throws a nancy left hook man.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Number one amateur wrestler in the
nation when it came out of high school
and he's so young.
Fought Internet.
What is he now?
23 2122 that's so Freddie Roach is that
he's the only guy.
Freddie Roach.
Co-Signs signs like this.
He came to 10th planet.
Right?
Remember I talked,
dammit.
I was trying to,
I was trying to convince them.
I had no idea what his,
his background,
his know his strategy.
Uh,
for his MMA career.
I had no idea.
All I knew was he came to me and he was
just fucking monster.
Ralph Torres is a debut debut.
Aaron,
come on Bro.
Did you roll with them?
Let me tell you this.
Let me tell you the story.
So he shows,
actually,
uh,
Joe texted me to go,
hey dude,
there's this fucking beast named Aaron
Peko new dude coming up.
He wants to train with you.
Like they were like looking for my
contact info.
And I said,
yeah,
yeah.
Have him have him texted me.
And then he texted me.
And to be honest,
seriously,
when people come through and they tell
me they're going to be a fighter and
they going to be a champion and they
wrestled 12 years seriously,
but herein Pinto,
I didn't,
I didn't know who he was at the this
point.
I didn't know it was,
he just told me he's just stepping aside
from Rogan though.
I'm just being honest.
I've ever sent you how many guys?
Uh,
shit,
I don't know.
Not a ton,
right?
Not,
it's,
I don't,
and I don't know where a guy's like
super legit.
And I'm like,
dude,
yeah.
So he texts me and,
and to be honest,
like that doesn't,
I just go to,
I just go to my class every night and I
teach my heart out.
If you want to join in on the class,
ah,
come on down.
If you,
you know,
I don't want to hear what the attitude
is,
why you're so fucking,
yeah,
I don't want it.
So I didn't get too excited.
You would treat a high school kid the
same way you would treat a college.
I just wasn't excited.
I'm like,
okay.
I got,
I got a bunch of motherfuckers I'm
training right now.
I got a lot of shit that I'm,
that I'm working on right now.
There's so much shit.
So he texts me,
he goes,
Hey,
Joe gave me your number.
Let's,
you know,
I want to come down.
I said,
yeah,
sure.
Come down.
And then,
then I just kind of like flaked on some
texts or something.
And then he finally just showed up and
he showed up and then I looked him up
and like,
Oh shit.
Okay.
So I had no idea that he's been working,
um,
to on being the ultimate like version
of,
he's our little brown,
like strategically as a fighter.
Got Chocolate Dell like chuck the bell
in his prime.
He wrestled.
So it's very hard to take them down in
there and if you did,
very hard to keep them down and that's
what he uses wrestling for.
But chocolate Dell was going to come out
and take heads off.
I had no idea.
That's what Aaron Picos strategy was.
So when I heard about them,
I like,
I pulled him to the side and I told him,
I said,
listen,
don't listen to anybody trying to tell
you that you can be like the best
striker in the world.
They're not people out.
This is what I was telling him.
I had no idea that he was trying to be
chucked without.
All I knew was that he was a stud
wrestler.
So I was like on,
this is the best advice.
If I was on my deathbed,
this is what I would tell you.
I would say fucking wrestle.
Take dudes down.
Pass the guard,
mount them them,
choke them.
That should be your number one strategy.
You're such an amazing wrestler.
Don't let anybody cause be sitting there
listening to me.
Meanwhile he's gone.
What the fuck is he talking about?
Cause I'm going to do the opposite of
what you're saying.
But he didn't say anything.
He didn't say anything.
So I kept reminding him this.
Every time he gets high,
he was just wanting to learn.
Jujitsu was a nice case he ever got
taken down and it ended up on the
ground.
He had no intentions of using his
wrestling to take people down and win
the fight on the ground.
He didn't know what to but every time
and remind him,
I'm saying the same shit over and over.
You know the guys he trains with,
they say them,
I fucker,
you know the guys who trained with the
best of the best,
he does not lose the last town.
I said,
cause you know,
then he fought his,
in his first fight he got caught with an
upper cut.
He got staggered and then he got
guillotine correct.
He bought a bigger guy first.
You can toot youtube wrestling
international guys like from Turkey,
Iran,
whatever when he was 16 but my church,
check this out.
So I'll tell you the story.
So I'm just,
let me just finish this story.
So even up to that point,
right after that loss,
I still didn't know that was his
ultimate strategy.
I didn't know.
So after that fight,
what I said was like,
you know what,
it was almost like a,
I told him,
let's turn your ass into that Khabib,
that GSP,
that unstoppable take down machine where
you smashed when the fuckers on the
ground and you fucking choke them out.
Let's do this shit.
This was after that first loss and then
I didn't hear from him after that.
I was over,
it was done.
So I guess this cat first kick,
because when he got clipped and he got
hurt and he got submitted,
I have you for me,
I was like say we should,
we should have,
you should have just washed all his
fights.
Yes.
Smile issue with them.
Cause because he trains with a
worldclass guys and like I said,
doesn't ever lose rounds.
He's so company,
he's like,
dude this isn't Tj dillashaw this isn't
this guy.
He goes,
I'm gonna smoke this guy.
So his respect isn't there yet.
And he just comes in cause he's knocked
down Miguel cotto so he comes in and it
got clipped him.
He just doesn't give us funding sources
though.
Before I forget,
let me just finish this.
So now,
once I realized that I was giving him
advice,
that was the complete opposite of this
whole training.
It all his coaches,
all his coaches were wanting to use the
wrestling to keep the fight standing so
he could use his,
it's a striking,
you know what I mean?
So,
um,
I then I finally realized that then he
went his own way and then you know,
it took me a couple,
two or three fights to realize the dam
never write shit.
This motherfucker can let me get too
excited.
I was wrong.
It's this mucky son that he's finding
no,
this is
the top featherweight.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
When this want to get a title shot.
Do you guys understand what I'm saying?
I understand now.
First some guys,
guys,
now at this point,
I just want to make this clear now at
this point I realized,
Damn Holy Shit,
they did have the right strategy.
He is an amazing striker.
I just went,
I was just going by,
that's your thing like no,
no,
just like the odds.
What are the odds?
I'm like,
dude,
we already know you're one of the best
wrestlers in the game.
We already know that.
That stick to that,
but you know what?
I had no idea.
That is striking is extraordinary.
So tough fight for him.
This is,
why do you say headed cross is a very
good fighter.
This is tough site by far,
but like I was talking to the belt
toward guys today,
the insiders that like it's not,
don't expect them to smoke them the
first round,
which I always think,
I think he finished them under four
minutes but like,
no,
no.
This is a tough one I find that I think
is critical for a young fighter that's
coming up is to not rely on any one
thing.
Now,
if you're talking about a guy who
doesn't have to rely on any one thing
you're talking about Aaron Peko,
you're talking about a legit worldclass
wrestler,
but if people know that you want to
stand and they know that you,
uh,
even though you're one of the best
wrestlers in the world,
you're not going to threaten them with
the take down.
That becomes an issue because there's
certain guys like gas on Bolanos or
there's certain,
there's certain boxers are strikers.
They got some nasty shit for your ass
and you,
you,
if you,
if they know for a fact you're not going
to take them down.
If you're standing up with Paul Daley,
okay,
and he knows for a fact you're not going
to take him down.
He's going to launch a left hook from
the moon.
He's going to hit you on your fucking
head,
but let me probably their plan B,
the plan b would be gone would be,
that's what I'm saying,
but it's not going to be good on the
fee.
Please let me finish.
The most important thing if you can do
all those things is that the other guy
has to not know what you're doing.
That was George Saint Pierre as greatest
trends.
Correct.
He never knew when he was punching you
or he's taking you down and you were
always,
you were always behind Koscheck fundings
jab,
double it.
So fucking good at that here and that.
And he's not the best wrestler and he's
not the best striker,
but he was the best at figuring out how
to do things.
You didn't know what was coming next.
Where are you rolling loaded for Rasa,
hobby and him or a phenomenal
combination cause for Ross is so
intellectually so smart and he's
thinking rationally.
He's not like,
you're going to go in there and you're
gonna fuck him up.
None of that.
Some of the problems,
it's all about overloading his mind.
It was all very rational,
very technique based,
very psychology based.
But the reason that meant what made that
GSP so good also is,
um,
he,
you,
you didn't know what he was doing,
but he was facing that high level
competition construct.
Matt Hughes,
Pico,
all these guys,
he goes,
oh,
I don't need to use my rescue.
So and knock them out of the bottom.
Shot this guy with him and crowds.
You're going to see the best version of
in Pico cause he can't just sit there
and fucking box with them.
You can see his wrestling.
I bet you're gonna see some different,
mix it up.
Do you have,
because he's never been pushed.
He's dominate to you.
Remember what John Danner told us the
secret to GSPS do you remember was that
when we're eating at that restaurant in
the head hair,
John did.
He goes,
he said,
the secret to his success is it's super
simple.
He's gonna either faint,
he's either going to faint jab or he's
going to actually really jab you or
faint takedown or actually take take you
down.
So that was always a faint before
everything he goes,
he's just,
he's always so,
you never know when that shot's coming.
Sharma,
my Pico GSP was the whole thing for asa
hobbies,
just so they're,
the two of them together worked so well
because they both have a great check of
their ego and an understanding of the
consequences and you rarely do right
hand and
they're both really,
really smart.
Told me cause he's trying with them all
the time.
Said that he's an amazing chess player.
Uh,
George.
So George is an amazing,
so he's really strategic and I feel like
he could always find
empty where,
where are you?
Where are you had a weakness near them
and that's where he was.
Well he was super open minded to men.
I mean they need like learn back kicked
from you are like yes,
like he just fed Eddie's place.
I felt so embarrassed that I'm uh,
I'm like,
I just felt like it was ridiculous that
I'm going to show him anything.
Do,
there's video on youtube of Joe Rogan,
Kevin Gsp,
but you know what,
fucking kicking lesson your back.
I knew I wouldn't ever have tried to
sell it to him if I didn't have
anything.
But when that came out of that same
meeting with dawn her when we were in
the restaurant donaher set it up cause
he goes,
I'm looking for,
and he told me afterwards that he set me
up.
He kinda had heard.
So He's like,
I'm looking for someone to teach gsp how
to throw a tuning sidekick.
His technique is off.
It's like we're going to fucking James
Bond movie or something.
It's funny with his accent.
So Carlos is 10 years older.
He's no Parkinson.
Yeah,
it's a tough fight for Pico,
but we still thinks pico gets it done.
But it's all about where's Pico at right
now?
It's all about where's he at right now
because one day he's going to be
unbeatable,
right?
Yes.
It's like he's 22 what is your 540540540
five yeah.
He's on this streak that if he can keep
up this intensity and he keep up this
mindset,
he's going to be a world champion.
The only thing that they could stop them
as a grave injury,
a grave injury or some sort of a mistake
in his thinking where he starts taking
things for granted or find some won't.
Fuck yeah,
we'll do a hot girl.
Crazy.
Now he's on a pass or nice.
He's what he's good at though.
The one thing that he got out of a
training at Hbcu is he's pretty God damn
good at twisters
standing like a fucking,
he lives for this shit dude.
He lives for this shit.
The thing is how long can he keep this
up right now?
He's doing it right now.
He's 22 he's making money.
He's a fucking savage.
Come on.
He started specials where he belongs
right here.
Look,
I mean,
he's just,
he does everything so well.
Everything from his de France two is
striking me.
I mean did he looks like a world
champion boxer when he's got his hands
up.
It doesn't mean he can't get caught.
Doesn't mean he can't get finished.
He can get a little reckless.
This mother got to keep your hands
getting,
he's going to be so good.
He hits so fucking hard,
dude.
That body shots his left took one of the
best law there.
Oh,
so kids,
when would the Duchy Oh shit.
Elbow got caught with a rabbit a little
bit.
We definitely got hit and rounds.
This is a real fight.
Morales hand corrals are tough.
Pico also has a crazy six pack to
what I telling you under four bro.
Oh,
the left hooks coming.
There's 1000 cuts coming.
Signs a little.
He's a little concussed.
Crosses.
Little concussed paralysis.
Morales.
Okay.
Paralysis.
Cream and corrals.
He's not totally needed.
The body shots too bad.
Be Smart.
Oh Shit.
Oh No.
Brendan just fell out of his fucking
chair.
Oh my.
Oh No.
That's what happens in firing.
That's what happens in fighting.
That's what happens.
That's what happens in fighty.
Holy Shit speech.
I don't like seeing a young man get hit
like that.
That was crazy.
Warm.
Brennan punched us this.
Watch this again.
Why?
Why is he
so reckless?
The savage,
but
look,
he's 22 he'll learn,
but what?
Watch this,
John Joseph and do this.
So he just,
he just wades in and you could tell the
corrals had recovered.
Look at this body shot.
Body shot hurts him there.
Hello?
Hello.
No snaps back out.
Cold out cold.
Two big bumps.
Look at this one more time.
Boom.
That's all she wrote,
Dude.
Everything goes down.
The drake of two on the way to,
on the way down his head is not,
that's not going to see again.
Look at this.
Boom,
perfect shot.
The lights go out in Georgia.
One too on the way down and then a third
one when he's already out cold.
Holy Shit.
That's some killer instinct right there
that could stop you.
You know you're talking about hubs
progression.
Well,
yeah,
the first look at him.
He doesn't know what happened.
He's,
he's,
he's trying to figure out what happened
now.
I mean,
he was comprende he's going,
fuck this mma stuff.
I understand my deathbed confessional
now.
Yes,
astral traveling,
but your,
your deathbed confessional.
You're correct.
He could have taken him down.
Who's going to stop Aaron Peko from
taking the cup.
He could beat him.
Here's the thing,
why not to do too,
but here's the thing.
You can do all things.
You can do all things,
but if you're standing
in front of a guy all the time,
if you get that guy hurt the way he got
done,
heart deck,
I hurt.
If your objective,
okay,
it's easy to be Monday,
Monday morning quarterback,
right?
But objective looking at right now,
I would say take him down,
take him down,
smash them up,
and then you take no damage,
no chances.
It's all variables.
It's all about mitigating variables.
You close all the variables down.
When you take God down a mountain and
start dropping elbows on his head,
you close all the variables.
If you can maintain the mount position
and keep trenching and you already know
he's fucked up,
it's all it's about of whether he's
going to tap the strikes or you're going
to get a choke.
I don't like seeing that.
Such a bummer.
It's a bummer.
It's a bummer,
but it's also not a bumper for Corolla.
It's like this game.
It's heartbreak and everybody needs to
see that.
Young guys coming up need to see that as
good as you are.
You've got to understand the mind.
You can't let yourself get sucked into
this path for glory where you're wild
and reckless and you're not keeping your
hands up and you're not respecting the
power of the guys.
Especially when you have the technique
though there's no reason to play that
game state that he may think he's a
fucking killer man.
He had the guy heard him and then just
all blood and was like,
fuck it.
It doesn't have the experience.
And then just came in and he's 22 and he
thought he could just smash that guy and
he hurts you.
It looked like he was going to think he
was going and he probably would have if
he fought technical,
but he,
he abandoned ship experience is he got
caught on a clench and this kid had him
here and he was hitting him with the
kingdom to the body twice and cross and
he clipped him on the chin with a
perfect punch.
Perfect right hand.
I mean his neck snapped,
his fucking head spun around and it was
perfect.
He was out cold before he went down and
on the way down he clipped him two more
times.
One more time.
When he was down.
I gotta buy a duplex.
Listen,
all three of you,
I've got to go to my wrap party.
I love all of them.
Come see me and Austin and miss the face
faders niche.
I got to go January 31 in fight.
Sure you don't wanna just stay for the
first round caspase.
It's definitely not going to go more
than one round.
Nope,
we're fine.
And Joe are going to open for me,
right?
I am out before you,
but you got to want to stay here.
Jamie's going to be there to recording.
It doesn't record.
He has a filling in.
It's two that hurts when you record
things due to enter peaker.
Right now it's going to,
what did her hand man don't.
I don't think he totally understands
even what happened because he still
thinks he's going to be world champ.
I still think you'll figure it out.
He certainly could.
Anything can happen.
He has all,
he just needs to fucking fight you.
Gotta fight technically.
Always.
And there's,
there's moments where you have to open
yourself up.
But the guys who do it correctly,
I'm gonna give you a perfect example,
style bender,
that motherfucker,
when he gets you heard he,
he goes after you correctly.
He does that run a Shin,
keeps control him down.
Defense a fucking push them down.
Yeah,
it was good.
He knows how to pass since there's no
way you're going to get knocked out from
the mouth.
You can knock a guy out from the mouth,
but he cannot even talk about great all
time mma strikers.
Let's talk about Anderson Silva.
Anderson Silva,
when he would hurt you,
he would take his time.
He would take his time and he would stay
focused.
And if he knew you were fucked up and he
knew he could just walk in and smash
you,
then he would take advantage of that.
Let's see this and watch this.
So,
so now he opera ca,
perfect upper cut.
He gets the guy hurt,
falls back and,
but look at this,
he moves towards him like,
like he can't hit him like he's can't
hurt them and look at him.
He just stays in that clinch and Pecos
right there when the right hand hits,
boom.
I see cause he stood right in front of
the guy.
He even when he was getting hit with
shots,
he never adjusted.
He just was bullying his way forward.
See He's bullying is way forward.
I mean look,
he got clipped and the guy who launched
a perfect right hand,
but my thing is pico really shouldn't be
standing in front of them right here
flipping a coin.
Okay.
Because maybe it's heads,
maybe its tail straight
upstairs to to the body and what
upstairs.
But my thing is if you're Aaron Peko one
of the best wrestlers to ever do mma,
why wouldn't you shoot right there?
You've got that guy in a position where
he's thrown wild shots that he wants to
knock out that gsps looking for that
dunk under,
right?
Yeah.
GSP is going to duck under shot,
take you down and then you fuck.
He's going to beat you up.
When you stand back up,
you're going to be bewildered and
exhausted.
He's going to hit you again.
He's a young guy,
man.
He's a young guy with flying phenomenal
talent.
But this is a lesson.
Take Ego and take your personality and
take your personal identity out of this
and look at this as this is these little
pieces that are moving around a on a
board and these pieces have properties,
they have values and they have,
they have powers and they have
weaknesses.
And if you watch these pieces play out,
like you're looking at a mathematical
algorithm,
you realize when there's flaw,
when can it go wrong?
Here's when it could go wrong.
We stand in front of each other and just
do this.
It can go wrong for everybody,
right?
Everybody that's ever lived,
go con.
Saki got knocked out by a Kaleel
roundtree with a perfect left hand,
right?
Go Con.
Slack is one of the greatest kickboxers
of all time.
It doesn't mean Cleo was not a great
fighter.
He's been very,
very high level fighter.
It's just anybody can get caught if
you're standing in front of city hall
can only take so much,
especially with those little gloves.
Think about all the fighters in MMA
history that have been known to have
rock solid Chin's.
All of them have one thing in common for
a while.
Then I never got hurt.
They never got rocked.
Right.
For Alaska,
like Dan,
he's got a great chin.
He does.
He's never been rocked and he's been hit
solid.
Right.
So we know that guy has a solid shin.
It's probably going to fall apart later.
You only get so many of those know
already with Pico.
He got rocked in his first fight and
this fight,
he got rocked.
Obviously.
You guys fight.
He got flour.
We know now,
so we know now that damn,
you know he's not,
he's not going to be known.
He's more to have the ultimate Chin for
sure.
I think he was hurt already.
I think it was hurt and even though he's
moving in for the kill,
I think he'd been tagged a few times in
the mix there and Pico.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I think there was a,
there was punches that landed and maybe
they didn't take him out and maybe they
didn't even make them buckle.
But all those,
when you get clipped,
have you ever walked into a door and
people don't know you walked in the door
and you can just keep walking,
but your head's like,
fuck.
Now imagine if you're in the middle of a
fight with the earphone.
I just bumped in your head.
The things shoved right into my ear lobe
or my,
um,
ah,
like a bitch.
Um,
but if,
if you get that many Kaos that early in
your career,
it's not a good sign.
I'm a pink.
Yes.
It's dangerous.
Maybe so as hard as fuck too.
That doesn't help either.
Boxing,
sparring gets Codo at his age.
It could be.
Yeah.
I mean,
those,
those things are luck.
Cumulus for Pico.
He's such an amazing wrestler that he
can actually,
he has the choice to go,
you know what?
I could go to go to my next fight and
the next fight after that and just,
you know,
uh,
trade fucking blows.
And it's like Russian roulette.
You could do that.
You can keep doing that.
Or You could just play it safe and go,
you know what?
I'm going to use my wrestling to take
this motherfucker down,
mountain his ass and could be these
motherfuckers,
this rule or by Brian.
One round dude.
One route.
It's going to happen.
It's your birthday.
One and maybe 10 minutes.
Maybe it'd be safe for 10 more minutes.
Do you tell them you're the life of the
party when you get there anyway,
this part is going to go on forever.
I bet.
Most of the cool there yet,
dude.
The main stars on fade.
Oh my God.
Come on.
What's his last fight?
The last fight ever.
It's fighting.
Writing better.
No,
you gotta stay dude.
Alright.
We love you man.
Happy Birthday.
Happy Birthday Dude.
52 hong kids.
Here's the Haiti.
Two more.
Eddie,
I think what you just said is very
important.
We said it's very important and this was
a really interesting thing that has two
choices.
Keep doing what you're doing or go
Khabib style,
but this is really interesting.
What happened?
What just happened?
Well,
there's three choices.
One is mixed,
both of them up like GSP.
The thing about GSP that's so
interesting is it wasn't just Khabib
style.
It was who knows what's going to happen,
who knows if he's jabbing.
The reason,
the only reason he was striking is cause
you just can't go in there at the bell
and take a guy down.
You got to set it all up.
He was always just setting it all up.
He was throwing jabs,
setting shit up.
But the number one mission in his mind
was to take his opponent down and play
it safe and mount him and pound them.
If you find the guy that you could take
that wasn't the blueprint with Josh
Koscheck.
Yeah,
well that was a blueprint with Johny
Hendricks.
He,
Josh Koscheck,
he jabbed the shit out of them.
I take,
everybody tries to take every fucking
body down.
GSP,
he didn't take his exam,
not because he didn't try.
It's hard to take down.
He tried a few times,
but he wasn't success to Josh Koscheck.
The game plan was literally to get them
to move forward.
So your number logo.
I remember when he was holding on to 99%
GSPS fights are designed to take the
fight to the ground.
They got real boring to,
let's be honest,
fellows,
an intelligent way.
I'm not saying it's not intelligent as
far as entertainment.
When he's saying that
that was fun.
He'll blow up a paper view for sure.
Cause you look great.
Phenomenal.
He's hands in La Right now.
Training with Freddy isn't,
they said he's real thin to looking at a
55 fight.
Wow.
And even though even though it could be,
does stand a lot and and play on his
feet a lot,
his,
his main objective is to take them on
the top and down.
That's the main,
that's number one.
But don't fuck around and throw some
strikes.
Why are they still talking about a floyd
mayweather fight?
It's embarrassing.
I don't know what the fuck they're doing
is just talking about,
I know he goes,
I like three fights left.
If it's up to me,
it's Tony Gsp,
GSP and floyd mayweather.
When I hear that I want to throw up,
but what do you think?
He just wants money and get the fuck
out.
Do you think he thinks he can beat him
cause he's such a savage.
Yeah they do.
You can't beat him.
Like they don't think floyd can knock
him out there in for a rude awakening.
Well he certainly bad.
Are you?
I mean maybe he lasts all 12 but they
get battered to fuck up will be awful.
But I mean,
you know what's going to be paid if
that's what you wanna do you get paid?
Do I?
I'd much rather see him fighting GSP.
Yeah,
me too.
But I don't think,
I don't think it's,
I mean it's a terrible move for him to
fight.
Floyd Floyd would just look,
floyd is the best box or maybe of our
era maybe of all time.
He's,
he's undefeated.
Here's the problem.
The UFC let connor do that once.
Now he's Kinda,
we can barely get him to fight is worth
$100 million.
And they're like,
do please fights.
Like,
Nah,
I make so much money,
whiskey and this,
I'll fight when I'm ready.
They're not gonna let that ever,
you're never gonna see that again.
I don't think you ever,
you see that crazy.
They may
disagree,
which is it can't happen now.
Now that the fertittas don't own the UFC
and now like this corporation owns it
now.
Everyone is not one day days is up the
hill.
No Way.
Wait,
what are you saying?
I'm saying that connor has so much
leverage now where it's not a good thing
to make someone a giant star who could
be a giant star because they're worried
that person's going to have leverage.
No,
they'll make them a giant star in the
UFC.
They're not going to let him jump over
and do a code promotion with floyd
mayweather again,
maybe put that and listen to keep doing
it.
Who else would they do it with theirs?
That's the better question.
Here's the thing.
If they had another connor,
they do it the same way.
It's a way to make money.
It's a smart way to make money.
It was a fun fight.
We watched it.
We got to seat.
You can sit education.
It's an education for people that
appreciate martial arts because you
really got to understand what a world
class top of the food chain,
maybe the best of all time box or does
to an MMA fighter and you think we're
going to pay for it.
The general audience,
he keeps saying for that.
I'm not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is is it was getting us
up.
It was good for the,
it was good for the sport and if someone
comes along different,
someone
comes along,
it's not floyd did someone else and the
same situation arises again and there's
another opportunity to make a shitload
of money.
They're going to do it again.
How many titles do they do?
See Floyd Floyd is 40 years old.
He probably doesn't want to do it that
many more times.
The only thing that would fuck floyd up
is that his extravagant spending isn't a
bad look for MMA too.
So let's say Floyd's 27 at this point
and he's one of the greatest and we go,
here's connor smokes him.
Here's can be smoked him.
Here's style.
Bench smokes him.
At what point is you have to be like,
this is a bad look man.
Like guys can fucking torched with.
Depends on whether or not it's obvious
that they had no chance.
Like with Connor,
the,
the interesting thing is like he landed
a couple of shots,
get up and you go,
okay,
if this guy could take this guy down or
even just kick his legs,
if Kinda could just kick his legs,
it would be a wash.
And it's interesting to watch someone
even fail against someone who's way
better at their sport.
The real question is,
you're ever,
are you ever going to see a worldclass
boxer?
By time we saw James Tony,
he had been like really late in the game
when Vince Phillips Fought Masato and k
one,
he was way late in the game.
They were on their way out looking for
money,
right after thoughts,
afterthoughts for the most part,
for the most part.
Do you ever think you're gonna see like
a,
uh,
a Crawford step into MMA aloma Chanko
step into MMA in their prime?
I don't think so.
Why wouldn't you do make so much money?
I know they need to make it so because
if they're at that level,
they're making so much money and you,
why would you risk going to the UFC in
50 years?
How awesome that put a poster is going
to be at conor and Floyd fucking
frame that she loves going to be 90 and
it's gonna be framed and I have that
shit.
I have the official one,
Joe Louis Max schmeling Dalia Gnocchi,
that poster in your living room.
You see?
See,
I'm all good on that.
I saw that.
It was a great spectacle.
I love being part of watching.
I'm glad killed the paper views.
I'm outman.
If someone else does it,
it's not as fun I don't think talking
about,
so if someone else comes along,
so you're telling me you same person
would and connor,
I'm saying it could be even floyd,
you'd be like,
well you're talking to degenerate.
I watch,
I watch women fuck in their underwear
beetle.
Okay,
me too.
Yeah,
I'm saying the masses.
I don't think,
God don't worry about the mat.
I don't think.
I don't think you're right.
Well,
that's what the UFC where think many
more.
If it could be stepped in and tried to
fight floyd right now.
Right now,
if they set it up in two months,
I guarantee you it would sell at least a
million.
It does better than conor.
You would want to say you think it does?
No,
I don't think those clubs at a million.
I said it does a million.
It could be boy Jamie for him.
Do you think you would do a million pay
per views or more or more something
like,
well,
here's the thing,
you do a million.
It's floyd.
He doesn't miss.
When uh,
who was um,
who was a floyd's last fall was it
Pacquiao and then Tim Bradley,
if I pack out then Tim Bradley never
tired.
Right.
And the pack,
you've got the giant,
the most paper view numbers ever.
But then Tim Bradley,
if I'm correct,
only got a few hundred thousand,
like 300,000 isn't that right?
Yeah,
that's right.
So then he fights connor and he gets
like 2 million,
whatever the fuck it was.
So giant paper.
You say Andre Berto,
Andre,
Bert and Jay Baer.
Thanks.
Right,
so he fought.
My apologies.
Tim Bradley.
So then he fights Andre Berto that only
gets 350,000 or something like that.
Pay per view buys.
Then he flights.
Conor fights connor and it's millions of
paper views.
If he fucked could be,
it would still be better than fighting
any of those other guys.
Agree.
100% Bradley like safe.
He had a fight with Bradley or saved.
No one's tuna.
No.
That's going to be that many pack.
Elvish fully male is probably,
you didn't get that against a big one.
That's a big one.
Especially bandy pack.
Hell now after we be broner,
after he got out that Australian dude
look good.
He looked very jeff [inaudible]
Australian guy.
He lost his power beats right.
TC,
Matisse and then knocked out my teeth
for 40 okay.
He's still good.
Yeah.
Prime.
But yeah.
No disrespect to Jeff Horn either.
I fucked that one up.
He's a math teacher.
He is a math teacher.
Do you see when Crawford fought him,
whoo.
That's when we realized how good
terrence can you realize he was the math
teacher?
Well,
Crawford is if he's not the best in the
world,
he's top two or three already said that.
I asked her,
I said,
who's the best?
He goes,
dad,
it'd be tough to go against Crawford
right now.
Notice nobody calls Crawford.
So to up to everyone challenged them.
No one really fucks with you about so
good at switching to switching stances
such a,
I think these fights,
you don't have a good win.
Well because of this promotion.
It's a fucking,
that's what's wrong with Buxton.
Joshua.
Eddie,
Huh?
Yeah.
Interesting.
Baiters going to take fade around.
You think so?
I agree.
And take them out.
I hope you door.
It's shown massive signs of Chin.
Uh,
dictation.
Well baiters in his prime.
I really fully believe that.
I mean when I saw him beat the shit out
of Montreal and take them down at will,
I was like,
I am so impressed too.
How about any starch King Moan?
Like 30 seconds,
dude,
he's a different guy.
When he moved over to bell tore two,
something happened.
And I mean it was almost like you
realize like,
Holy Shit,
I'm not even in the UFC anymore.
I got to really make something here.
When he built beat Phil,
you know,
he's,
he's beaten some really good guys.
Man.
He's really good guys.
When you look at them like everything
about him,
like technically the way he's moving,
the way he fights,
and he's a good example of what we were
talking about earlier.
You don't know what he's gonna do.
He's gonna take you down.
He's going to strike with you.
He's doing everything and he's mixing
everything up and his mentality.
Yes,
he's a fucking end.
His mentality.
The other thing he was telling me is,
uh,
so he was trying to negotiate with Bell
Torres contract.
This is his last fight,
his contract.
So hold up,
you're going to be a free agent and be a
double champ champ,
because that's,
yeah,
we're risking that.
Like holy fuck if you own the light
heavyweight title and heavy,
we tell you about to get paid.
And I said,
well,
how about a super fight with DC?
Whoa.
Double Champ.
Well,
the thing is,
although he's famous in,
you know,
the Bella tour circle,
how many people know who we is of Bella
tour?
I mean UFC ultimate fighter winner,
bro.
Forget in terms of pay per view buys.
People forget they need to see you
there.
If they don't see you there they go.
Where's he been?
You don't think you can sell double
chamfers double champ.
You can sell it if you're willing to
acknowledge Palatar they never have.
They never acknowledged fade or they
never acknowledged when he was fighting
in pride,
like they never thought.
They literally didn't even want me to
say pride.
They don't want to acknowledge other
organizations,
especially back then because pride
fucked them over.
Remember they had that whole sneaky deal
like they gave him chocolate dao and
vandelay is supposed to come over here.
Then they reneged.
It was a disaster,
shady shit and I was still,
as a person who's a martial arts
commentator,
you have to bring up fade or you had to
bring up [inaudible].
You had to bring it up.
A lot of the people that were making big
noise over in Japan and he was one of
them.
He didn't cool if they had opened it up
to so we could see who's the absolute
best in the world.
Beta is really good.
He's really good.
And I really would,
I would be very curious to see how much
better he's gotten because sometimes
guys turned a corner and then all of a
sudden they just become the best.
We tough to tell again.
That is his opposition right now because
Michio and right,
he was in him and he was never a world
beater in the UFC.
I mean he was at a top five guy.
You know what I'm saying?
Like he's never contender really good.
Um,
but then still Phil Davis,
no field.
Dale says guys beat a lot of fucking
good people and fills another one who
looked better once he got to bell tour,
he looked better.
Like he like hit,
he turned a corner as well.
And then when you're,
is a new chapter in your life like that,
you've got to rise to the occasion.
And the Chemo Chemo off see older and
his career and it fade or oldest shit in
his career.
So it's like we,
I don't know what Beta is that.
There are great wins though.
Yeah.
And at light heavyweight,
he would kill right now in the UFC,
there's no button.
Anyway,
once Bella Tor stars started signing
with the UFC,
like with Chandler and Alvarez and I
champs Alvarez,
Albert's
channel in that way and now ben ass
grin.
Yeah,
you can't,
you can't say shit about Bella tour no
more.
No,
no.
Exactly.
You're trying to take,
when Bella tour fighters are being
signed to the UFC based on their
stardom.
Bella Tours legit as fuck.
Oh,
super legit.
Especi a certain weight classes for
sure.
One of the best on the planet.
You know,
people would lit.
Yeah,
he'd be Woodley.
I mean [inaudible] Musashi is absolutely
one of the best in the planet.
Hand Chandler has beaten Alvarez,
Alvarez,
one of the best on planet challenge ones
live or go to the UFC.
He just see style.
He likes being over there.
Here's the argument to Ben Henderson,
UFC worldclass comes the Bella tour.
It's been a struggle.
It's been struggles,
cynical.
He fought course club,
which I don't think was the right move,
that terrible idea to whereby this is
not his weight class.
He's just say five pounder.
And I love Ben Friend of mine,
but he hasn't looked like the same ben
that you know,
compete against Frankie Edgar.
And that's true.
But you have to remember that he's been
fighting world class competition for
ever.
So as the Debbie and bees,
yes.
Rice rest true.
And you cannot stop it.
Yes.
But Eddie Alvarez was later,
he came along,
his career was hard and rough,
but it was later in in the,
in the time period.
Then ben underground kitten.
Yeah.
Henderson was like WC,
right to showtime.
Showtime.
You got to remember he was the champ.
So pet is,
takes his title with that crazy kick to
close out WEC.
They go over to the UFC.
He,
he beats every,
I mean fights.
Everybody.
He fought so many fucking tough guys.
So many guys,
you know.
And then didn't he fight?
He got stopped by dos Anjos when dos
Anjos was one is up.
Come on.
Dos Anjos is on the way to the title.
That was the big fight was him and
Henderson needs Cko dumb.
Yup.
He was a motherfucker back then.
Dos Anjos for that time period.
There was a time period of like two
years where I think dosantos was just a
fucking berzerker like one of the best
lightweights of all time and then,
and it's not,
I don't know.
It could be a coincidence.
The new side of came,
he went on to lose weight.
I'm just,
I don't know.
That will never go into 70 he's a
fucking monster has 70 he's not as good
at 70 as it is is 55 fucking good at 70
now the guys like Camaros Uzman it's
going to be a problem for the guys like
Colby Covington,
undersize,
big strong wrestlers.
It could become a hard time to find
fighters.
Go from Bella Tor to the UFC or you have
seen a bell tour no matter what in that
debate,
the one,
the cream of the crop or change is the
level of prestige and the belt,
the UFC belt,
the UFC.
It's king.
No matter what it will be because you
have to go through a tougher road to get
that,
but it's also,
it's not even like saying a and B,
it's like saying a and f.
There's so many separations between the
Bella,
our belt in the UFC talking about the
prestige,
but when you're talking about town,
Douglas Lema in my opinion,
is one of the best welterweights on
planet earth.
Rory Macdonald who beat him in a very
close decision,
one of the best welterweights on earth.
[inaudible].
He's one of the best middleweights on
the fucking planet.
These are,
these are all realities mad for anybody
who understands mma,
but yet the belts just different cause
you don't crawl through the same shit
that you'd have to.
If you're in the UFC,
UFC champ,
dude,
you better be you're,
you're the best.
Your hands down the best.
Yeah.
If you bought 55 you walk away,
you know chocolate.
Dell is always going to be a former UFC
champion hoists crazy UFC champion,
beat three champions,
all these cha,
you fc,
it means more.
It's always going to me more.
It's like q tips,
cotton swabs,
q tips.
It's easy to get signed to the UFC and
fighting the prelims.
Then to go from the prelims to the main
card,
that's for sure.
Harder to get in there.
Get on the other road ahead.
Lord.
You know a hardy at 145 pound woman,
then they'll let you right in.
Yeah,
exactly.
Fight for a title fight.
But you WWII superstar.
Who Do they,
what do they have?
Cyborg fight.
Now if Amanda Nunez decides to take time
off of fighting at featherweight,
I've shunock's outside board.
Who Do they have cyborg fight again?
Megan.
She won her fight.
But how crazy is the way she won a deal?
What are you going to do?
Fight,
fight,
fight again.
You've got to do a read.
That's what I read.
That's what I,
and then just leave Cyborg on the
sidelines and not hide her enough.
She gets pissed.
Think you need to have like a,
a technical foul and accidental foul and
that's the end of the fight.
Cause if it's,
if it's,
it's a foul.
If you poke someone,
how the fuck is it?
Not if a foul if your toes,
and he seemed to fix that.
No one.
If you just throw a punch,
if you throw a punch and as you're
throwing your ride hook,
your thumb goes in someone's eye and
they stopped the fight.
They look at the replay,
they say it's an eye poked.
The referee says it's an I poke.
You get disqualified.
How is that any different than you
throwing a round kick and the the,
the toe inadvertently goes in your arm.
It's just snap.
It's not meagan's fault.
I mean,
she did what she was supposed to do.
She's tracking her down using a range.
Lands a nice kick butt.
She caught her at the toe,
toe in the eyeball,
but also cat turned her back and wave
like it's over.
But she has to say it's over.
Sheriff fucking eyeballs popped.
Whatever it happened.
It cut right here.
How weird is it that there's a shortage
of big women?
You think they would be an abundant?
Really,
really?
You can't blame Julie Girls who are all
in the wwe,
NBA all.
No one wants to punch in the face.
Think about it.
There should be a shortage of 150 115
pound girls.
There's no,
there's a ton of them.
It if you get like a vow,
this frank [inaudible] shout out to
Frank Trigg,
you get Valentine is shifts waco get a
Valentina Eddie.
If you get a a shift Shankar and Amanda
Nunez or Rhonda Rousey,
this is like a hundred of those on the
earth.
You know the ones who can read,
there's no,
the ones who could really transition
from kilcoy Christian or kickboxing.
There's some bad ass Moy Thai girls,
but they might be wrapped up in Moitai.
They might be Miriam Nakamoto or
something like that.
They really ever going to go back to
mma.
She's trying to just get some injuries,
man,
she's like 41 I think,
you know,
and she's working her way.
Hobby where came out way back to you and
bang.
She's um,
she's a beast and as a Meu tie fighter,
she's a monster and there's a few of
those girls that are that way with mma
or that way.
What you Jitsu.
It's,
it's finding them all in mma.
You're,
it's less than 102 but girls under this,
uh,
what's,
the weight class?
Fucking rose fights in Tatiana Suarez.
The motherfucker.
Tatiana swartz fights 25 and 15.
She fucked 25 and lost to Valentina and
good fight.
He fight.
But Valentino just seems to be stronger.
More physically powerful.
Logist a little sharper.
A little more suited to 25.
She's almost like a tweener.
It's like Yolanda is like not quite one
15 knocked one 25 cash in a weird,
well you were that little man.
Five pounds means a lot more than 10
pounds.
One 85 dude faders,
walkouts or,
oh,
he's epic.
Yeah.
Like look at his sneakers.
Like you just found those somewhere.
Somebody's going,
he says put these on and can't go
barefoot.
Definitely not Reebok's.
We know that.
What do you think they are?
Sauconys new balance.
New Balance.
Tsa.
Yeah.
Probably not even the TSA.
New Balances we can always get that
wouldn't cross man kisses.
It goes through the whole deal.
I,
there's someone in the media asks him if
he Christ and he said once,
wow.
Yeah,
once I did chopping onions.
That's it.
Fuck man.
What do you think he loses?
Probably last time for him.
Huh?
Um,
you never know man.
I mean,
he might just be like,
be really bored with everything else in
his life and willing to take the
punishment.
This is the real question.
When,
when a guy's his greatest fade or it has
had a career that fader has had and
still wins every now and then,
like knocked out frank,
Frank Mir,
he soda and chill son and he still can
win.
Right?
He's still can beat good guys.
And B,
you know,
real quality UFC fighters that have
transitioned over both those guys,
you know,
chill son and was a quality fighter.
Frank Mir is quality fighters.
The heavyweight champion.
It was to tell him,
you can't keep doing this.
This is probably the most funny ever has
ever all day.
What does he do?
He doesn't say anything.
And he eats ice cream.
He draws pictures,
give him a chance.
He gets into that cage and he,
so he reignites the fuel inside of him
that led him to be,
if not the greatest of all time in my
eyes,
top three,
top three.
She,
the thing is all about time period.
It is about time period.
But it's also about what happened when
they fought for a preschool for dooms
gotta be in the argument
but then Solos.
So to steep it,
you gotta do for you had to do cane can.
Yes.
Yeah.
I think those are the guys in particular
order.
You don't need just the format that's
Mount Rushmore of heavyweights.
The argument for,
for ratio,
for doom is very strong because he beat
him off to a great aussie pay out him in
the first round.
He got reckless,
the street bay,
Cayo de and then uh,
uh,
Volkov k owed him to,
to your,
to your point with fader and you're
like,
Yo,
it's cool.
He gets up there.
He gets,
sorry.
You're cool with Liddell and Tito.
Keep doing it.
But this is a difference between them,
first of all,
because fate or stayed active.
And I was cool with Tito.
What I was when it was not cool with was
chuck didn't look right.
He didn't look like he was prepared,
even though,
I don't know,
he didn't look like he was prepared on
the meds.
I don't know where he's at.
I don't know where he's at physically.
I don't know what damage he sustained.
When I see fade or fight,
he wins or he loses like Montreal and
chaotic.
But I think that shaft fight though,
it wasn't good fight.
And I think that shot that Michio on
Keto road with,
he does chaos.
A lot of people touches anywhere on the
chin.
You're going to sleep.
He fucking sofar athlete freak
in the NFL for six years and he's so
light on his feet and he's fast as like
a tank.
Yeah.
So did he knocked out Derrick Lewis and
like 15 seconds to still took it to
them?
Yeah.
I don't think it's indicative of fate or
being done.
You see the model.
So yes,
it's as resilient as it used to be.
Maldon owls and underrated boxer.
Maldonado touched him up and he's a
Brazilian Zombie,
but he,
yeah,
he's really should be fighting at one 70
if he didn't eat all the assets in the
world and he gave fucking feed or it
everything it had done,
both won that fight.
He tried to fucking reverse it in
Russia.
They're like,
what are you at your fucking mind?
It's Russia.
He would get the fuck out of here.
He's trying to like get them to do a,
yeah.
In Russia or best friends with hooten
for fuck sakes.
Yeah.
I can't shit reverse there.
Why?
Why are these marines coming in?
They come in for [inaudible] was in the
middle.
They're doing a national anthem.
I don't know why.
Oh,
they're doing a Russian national anthem.
Oh my.
Just scare and fate or with guns.
They brought a gun in the oxygen for
your fate.
You're a fuck about it,
but I wanted to eat that.
They bring guns into the octagon.
That is odd,
right?
It's a ritual.
I understand.
Ritual,
not a ritual.
I got shoes on too.
Right?
They got shoes on both those things.
A lot of shoes in that.
It's not about that.
When I say what is happening,
are they going to shoot those guys with
a medicine for the troops shot holes
through the ceiling?
I would celebrate that,
but they do a whole thing where like
giving back to troops and shit.
Is that what they're doing here?
Yeah.
Okay.
So he's saying,
Oh shit.
Check out this guest Craig Morgan genes.
Who's that guy?
Is he singing America?
America?
When we hear this shit,
will they faders right?
Yeah.
Well this guy is going to sync both of
them,
but it's going to seem to rush one all
fucked up.
Don't get
defeated.
Okay.
Oh shout out to black rifle coffee.
Leejay Jeremy.
Okay.
It's gotta be all the way up.
Sorry.
They guy like Siki came out.
Stand up.
Hot Topic.
We can only hear it if you'd take your
earphones off,
Jamie.
I know,
I know.
I don't have it.
I can't tell you doing that on purpose.
It's not fed into the show.
Right,
but can you make it a little louder?
Barely keep going.
There you go to down.
We have to sit through.
The [inaudible] going to get recorded
and there's a lot.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
All right.
You can kill.
Did you seem to do the Russia one too?
That's a such a or it takes too long.
Well,
we were talking to your showtime buddy
about that.
Like why do do this with the fights?
When is your owner and pack you
[inaudible] they had to do both.
Anthems.
Yeah.
It takes forever.
It's like 10 more minutes.
Oh,
look at that.
That star spangled banner.
You mother Fucker,
look at that flag flying in the
background.
Do you know who this gentleman is?
Craig Morgan is just a country apple
watch on how dairy.
That's race.
He's a veteran as a country duty at
apple.
Watch on.
Yeah.
That seems like I'm not buying in.
You're not buying it.
I'm not buying it,
but you're faking,
bro.
Yeah.
Is that an apple watch?
That's an apple watch.
Do you also those how those fucking
Chris daughtry wristbands,
he's winning.
That ain't fucking very country either.
Countries at different things now.
It's all the same core to Georgia line.
Yeah,
a little bit country.
A little bit.
21 forever.
Yeah,
forever 21 and I dig it and I take it.
He liked those kinds of pants,
not his pants.
This boot cuts or give me some
predictions.
I'm a Ryan Bader,
a Tko second round grandpa first radio,
first round.
And Jesus said he keeps showing me
respect or knock him out in the first
round.
Ryan Bader.
Oh really?
Wow.
Eddie's been on one tonight though.
Yeah,
that'd be right.
I hate to ruin it for you.
I think if Ryan doesn't respect for it
fade or he can get cracked.
Well here's the thing about bait or to
as much as we love Bait Beta,
I'm high,
I'm so hot.
Remember when he and his big fights,
like he lost a rumble Johnson.
John Jones,
like a lot of the big moments,
he gets caught up sometimes Johnson shot
a bad shot and fucking he bounces head
to the moon.
So this is the finals of their
heavyweight tournament tournament.
That would make Ryan Bader be the
heavyweight champ champ champ.
Champ.
Channy owns the light heavyweight one
right now too.
Yeah.
What's up?
John Jones trying to run it back,
Bro,
those years ago.
Are you bringing up old shit?
Is that he says,
well you bring up old shit.
It's run it back.
Is that what he said?
Nope.
That's what I'm saying.
Terrible,
terrible champ shit.
Right?
Yeah.
Hey Bro.
[inaudible] started it and now fucking
everyone wants to do it.
Well,
there's a few guys.
I like that.
I love it.
It ties up the division so it gets a
little messy,
but
I'd love to see,
could be,
but 70 and would at least go to 85 is
the belt and 45 there are 35 pound belt.
He goes going to go out there.
Here's the thing,
I really believe this.
I think if some,
this is an egregious error and there's a
fight that stopped prematurely.
I think you should almost put it up to
the vote of the Internet.
I really do it all at you.
At your God damn mind
vote.
Yes.
Popular vote.
Didn't you say most people like 70% of
the punctuation of dummies?
No,
it's like 80 it's about the popular
vote,
amy.
Okay,
but let's say,
how about we have and say,
how about we have an organization of
esteemed ladies and gentlemen,
an organization of maybe 200 excepted
martial artists,
worldclass martial artists,
people that a committee of a hundred
people is what the fuck they're doing.
You're going to get the decision,
right?
That's a great idea.
If you have it so much better than the
Internet trolls voting John Hackleman
ends and John Donna,
hers and for Rasa hobbies and duke roof,
Greg Jackson,
Mike Winkeljohn,
Trevor Whitman is,
and you got a committee of the whole
eastern
friends.
You
believe you do have something like that
Duane lushy fear.
If you have those Tom's girl,
if you had all those people in like a
database and they all put in their
opinion,
you would be 100% probably in agreement,
especially if the experts,
yeah.
All right,
here we go.
Fade or looking,
stoic,
kind of nervous.
I'm kind of nervous for Ryan.
Well,
it's scary,
man.
He's fighting to fade or bro and he
comes out.
They get,
you know,
as he's older,
he definitely didn't give a fuck
anymore.
He just wants to take your head off.
He's a second round hammer on my watch,
bro.
He's looking for that hammer.
Could that right hand feed or it's just
got that left hand loose and that right
hand balled the few fucking Pico is ever
going to lose again.
So I have,
I don't know what's going to happen.
Hey man,
anything could happen.
It's still one of the greatest
heavyweights of all time.
And Ryan Bader is a better fighter than
he's ever been and and really slick man.
He's smart.
He's smart and his approach.
Oh.
Oh,
what's up bro?
What's up?
I told you to holy shit is Lucky Eddie,
but call it dude.
He's got a sneaky left.
Took the term,
done this,
this fucking tournament.
Beat mitre.
Own Fuck.
Did I just starch fucking fade or two?
No one starts his fate or luck
and it was a weird left.
Took like it was almost like it looked
like it start out as a jab and then
we'll turn it over at the,
at Arizona state left hook,
like how rose knocked out.
You are a racks.
So yes,
I want to see that.
Holy Shit.
Call it the top shelf gods were
grabbing.
It keeps the cookies trying to tell you
guys,
you guys the listen top shell.
Damn.
Look at this.
Watch this.
Watch this left hand.
It's almost like a jab he draws,
which she was going to fake the single.
Oh Yeah,
look at that again.
So crazy good for him.
Was that's a good stop.
Stop.
There's two shots.
Gosh,
that was almost like that Dan Henderson.
Bisbing shot that extra shot.
Do you think that's bad?
That's evident.
Watch this again.
Is that evidence of fader?
We just can't take a shot or is it a
perfect punch or is it both?
Hey,
there has heavy fuck.
I think it's both.
I think it's,
he's getting forward a little bit of
that.
It's a little bit of both,
but damn,
it's a perfect punch.
He,
he dropped his shoulder down like you
almost like he's going to jab to the
body,
right?
Yeah.
It looked like almost a shot.
Jack Damn Dude Five.
I was about to get paid.
So what happens now?
He's a free agent.
They've got to pay the cow.
Look at the heavyweight Kaos light
heavyweight champ.
Kale.
Shout out to be a left.
Right.
Shout out to Ryan Bader
man.
It's party.
You sad to watch fate or get cracked
like that.
Oh Wow.
Interesting.
Well just cause I'm up.
They just my
who wouldn't listen,
you did call it dude and he's texting,
he's texting.
Everybody told you bitch told you
motherfuckers I see his car.
At a certain point you just can't take
shots and just can you get hit.
That wasn't a,
that was a nice shot,
but it didn't appear to me.
You know that it was the heaviest shot
ever.
I hate to say I told you so to anybody,
but to young fighters,
this kind of shit is what I'm always
trying to point out.
Don't get caught up in the moment.
Don't get caught up in wars because
every one of those bull,
eventually there's gonna come a time
when that credit card bill is going to
come and you got all these charges and
it just,
you don't have the money you're going to
have to pay,
but it's going to have to pay.
There's no way around it and if you
fight a smart calculated fight,
like,
like who the fuck gets hit the least in
mma?
You can definitely say ask boy's style
bender.
Well wonder boy,
it's been dropped
Levodopa for a long time.
He saw a lot of time.
I think aspirin is probably the number
one,
but he's never fought anybody at the
caliber of the UFC.
Like in their prime.
He's gonna,
he's gonna now we're going to find out,
but just avoid it.
Whatever.
You can do it.
Again,
John Jones really doesn't take damage
either.
They sell calculate and just such a
fucking beast.
The for the young fighters too.
The other thing is,
is you train,
you do all that work in the gym,
all that work,
and then you're,
and you have these advantages,
those even out when you're playing rock
'em sock 'em then all that work,
you all have that game plan.
You're coaches,
you're disrespecting them.
Cause now it's level playing field.
Whoever lands first,
it's fucking [inaudible] Nunez.
Yes.
There you go.
Same thing.
Didn't respect the game.
Thought she could just steamroller
walked towards her solution was going to
blow her out of the water,
pinned her up against the cage and Nunez
cock cock cow.
Ractor correct.
And that's what happens.
This is,
this is one person fighting on a
narrative and fighting on emotions and
trying to just overwhelm someone in Pico
and the other person responding and
catching someone,
whether it's these openings,
Aaron Peko same thing.
I mean he was pressing forward,
pressing forward and he gets,
it gets hit with that fucking haymaker
of a right hand.
Do you think that fate or side piece or
is that as translator?
She's with him.
Every translator.
She's the translator.
Um,
I'm uh,
know I'm very impressed.
How can you not be impressed next for
Beta though?
I'm a bait.
Should they wait for this fight to 40 to
40?
Was he two 40?
I don't know.
I think two 30 what's find out.
So you've uh,
Jamie get the way it looks good.
It looks like Tiki.
Like dude,
he's solid.
Fucking two 30.
I'll tell you that.
That's a legit heavyweight.
I mean he can definitely make two oh
five.
Oh no,
that's wrong.
She cuts the official Bella tore a
Wayans.
See if they have it.
There's this wifey is super pumped man.
He's a champ champ now.
Scott Cole and he's a free agent.
Bet on himself.
What does that,
he's the heavyweight Grand Prix chip.
Yeah.
10 Line 7.8 to 27.
Okay,
so kind of a light heavyweight kind of
light.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's got three belts.
What happened there?
I don't know.
You give him another one.
Have another one bro.
Cause that was awesome.
Oh that one has jewels on it.
That one's better than the UFC belt.
The new UFC belt.
Doodoo yeah.
Um,
I wonder why they changed it just to mix
it up.
But why?
I don't know why now here,
and here's the thing.
Now if you're a champ,
so uh,
let's see.
Tony becomes champ and he hits that
belt.
They don't give you another belt.
They just added another stone to it.
Budget cuts was a real eye.
That's,
that's the word.
That's the rumor that you don't get new
belt.
They just add stones to you.
Swear to God.
I would negotiate that in my contract.
I like you gotta give me another fucking
belt.
I want the old bell.
I want a legacy about those old belts
are so sick.
That spelled of all time.
Maybe I just don't like change my look
at him like got that looks like uh,
we went to step back.
It's like when portion went from the
nine nine three to the nine,
nine,
six,
those goofy lights,
they'll never
understand what the hell that and then
fortunately the unfortunate was 100.
But you know what's great about Porsche
went five apps and my bat,
let's round them up again.
You guys like those will run them.
Get UFC goes,
fuck that.
You guys are going to take this shit.
We gotta occupy them down the fucker.
I love the UFC.
Love the EOC.
Yeah.
Not the belt though.
How can you not love the UFC?
Um,
our belts necessary.
I like them.
Right?
Of course.
Rings.
When can we did that?
Look how he did that.
Very interested.
How about fate or dink?
Throw one punch.
And I caught him.
Perfect man.
I want to see that Walmart.
Watch how he does this.
I really liked this.
Dips his left shoulder and loops it in a
weird arc,
man.
Watch this.
Ooh.
Like half a jab.
Half a hook.
It was like this,
right?
What's it like this so low?
It's like this long.
And he caught them at the very end one
here.
Would he say?
Yeah.
I don't think they'll let us.
If he gets on that,
he's like d you fucking Pussy
Pico.
Come judge
just drops the ultimate fucking,
yeah.
Um,
I think he's probably,
if I was him,
he's real humble.
I think I'd probably say I'm super
thankful and thank my team and,
uh,
it was an honor to fight,
fade or thanks a lot.
Not Pay me.
Not Smart,
amy.
No,
he's too smart and look good looking
guy.
Articulate as he's knocking
motherfuckers out like fade or,
I mean that's a real heavyweight
champion.
You want that guy as your champ do.
He has so many belts on him right now.
And that one has diamonds and I want to
put those down so you could use your
hands.
No,
don't dude.
I'd wrap them around my neck so I can't
see.
Put One on your head.
Like a turban.
Yeah.
And then put the oil on my face and talk
to them like,
Hey,
you guys want to go?
You guys want to go see her doing versus
Gordon Ryan.
I can't,
I can't go to Mexico.
No,
it's had in Mexico.
It's an la.
We might use it
when,
that'd be Friday,
February 22nd it's going to be on fight
pass and a great fucking
flag.
And Josh Barn,
it's a four man tournament.
Josh Barnett,
uh,
Rustam Chizzy IV.
Who?
Who,
who fought Gordon Ryan in the finals of
the bi six.
That's where Eba,
that's where Rob Gordon,
Ryan was born,
that he won the absolute of Ebi Ebi,
six hours his first tournament.
This is combat [inaudible] badge meant
to slab.
So it's barn and not do companies just
don't get to Gordon Fabrice format
attorneys combat Barnett be sick.
It's going to be fucking crazy.
It's an amazing tournament.
Yeah,
it's going to be crazy dude.
Cause Josh Barnett just got beat by
Gordon Ryan too.
He got to know it could be a rematch
there and Rustam thou he was in the
finals and Gordon beat him in the finals
of the absolute Ebi six.
So there's two re potential rematches
alone.
But then on top of that you got fuck
buddies over doom versus Gordon Ryan in
round one I think.
I think dawn Gordon,
Ryan,
I think Gordon Ryan is obviously,
he's the best thing in Jujitsu,
but he wants to mma too with his
personality,
his skillset.
I think he's gonna take over him and may
too.
He's a motherfuck.
Well he's,
it seems like Donna,
hers is a personality to right way to
Donna.
Her is telling him like,
you're going to learn how to strike
first.
You're not going to go in there without
any skills and joy attack his Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is going to be,
you know,
to be good for him.
It's going to,
you know what?
He'll do fine because if you watch his
last few fights,
he likes to mount.
He's not like this big leg locker,
leg locker.
He's an expert at leg locks.
He's got that whole system down,
but he likes to mount under Jack and get
arm triangles and that's perfect for mms
aren't triangles in mma.
That's one of the,
that you have to be a savage with arm
triangles.
If you're fighting MMA plus this person,
how you cause a star is a star.
Yeah.
Well it was a handsome kid.
He's got a 28 pack tattoo on his chest,
on his chest,
might have the most ridiculous six pack
of all time.
His him and Wiz Khalifa should have a
six pack off.
Wiz Khalifa is the size of this.
My,
he doesn't count,
but he's got a ridiculous,
it's like saying that it's starving kids
in Africa shredded.
Oh,
you guys going to be in town February
22nd?
I think I'm in town.
I,
if I'm in a crowd of 100%,
they're going to be there.
You know,
he's,
he's parked sponsor like ranch.
Uh,
well the guy that's uh,
his partner in that owns Copper Gel.
Uh,
yeah,
they gave me some of that.
So Copper Jealous,
sponsoring legitimate look at him.
Look at it.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm not lying.
No,
I know he's shredded,
but you,
you compare her Wiz Khalifa,
these guys,
but you don't count.
Stop.
Stop and give the man his propers.
Let's see.
Wiz,
Wiz Khalifa.
Show me that.
Super.
No,
no,
not like Wiz.
No wiz has muscles like thick ass on
that TV program.
I don't know.
Look it up.
Seriously.
Dow three pack,
but they're like jumbo,
but they don't
separate in the middle.
There's a solid,
it's just,
um,
they just,
they're so dense.
All he's doing is Moy Tai.
He does Moitai like crazy.
Put on 30 pounds of weight.
Moitai do that to you.
Yeah.
You've got to go to the right Taco shop.
He can to get them.
Fuck.
Yeah,
but Gordon rides more impressive and
also Gorg Ryan is 200 and it doesn't
have to go chocolate body.
You can consider that.
That's true.
What does he weigh now?
Uh,
he's probably to 25 do you need do
something crazy and get two one 70 like
within a year or two ago?
Well,
yeah,
he used to be.
He used to fight at one 70 that's
credentials.
He decided to bulk up how many picos all
of them.
It no killing it.
Who's testing?
Nobody's testing.
If we got Picos and your Usada,
you're good.
Here's the thing.
If you are a young guy and you're
indulging in various ways to enhance
your physical recovery and then you get
off of that stuff,
you're going to have an adaptation
period.
And that adaptation period,
I mean this is an issue.
It's,
hold on.
Why is it an issue,
Joe?
It's not an issue.
Well,
the issue is your performance is going
to suffer.
You're saying if you're getting off it,
if you're on it and you get off of it,
he's a young guy.
If he's on it,
we're assuming he's on,
which we don't know.
Gordon.
Yeah.
Oh,
I don't know.
What would you say?
Just have phenomenal genetics.
Okay.
All jokes aside,
if you do find someone,
no,
not him.
Let's say someone else.
Let's say he just has taken Jeanette,
someone else that does it.
If they do do it and they're doing it in
an untested forum,
like like submission,
grappling,
correct.
Which most you can get away with
whatever you want.
Correct.
Eddie Meyers,
speech outline,
generalists tests like in the speaking
completely.
Honestly,
we know for a fact that some competitors
are indulging.
I don't know that.
Okay.
Awesome.
Well,
all I'll say from I would say yes.
Okay.
I'm sure some are.
Okay,
well,
I'll just shoot it to,
we know for sure some are,
you know what?
Not accuse any individuals,
but we know for sure summer when when
you do have that situation where someone
is on something and then they get off of
something,
then you have this adaptation period
where they're,
their body's not producing testosterone
as much anymore.
They're going to have to get on
something else in order to kickstart it
back up.
But you can do that.
He can do that.
But here's the thing too,
you know with this John Jones thinking
the Pico granting and he did test
positive now with Vata,
right?
And they still allow him to fight.
Well now let's say you are a Jujitsu guy
who comes to the UFC and you did do
stuff prior and those Pico,
Pico Graham's get flagged,
right?
What'd he intends entirely on what
you're,
what you're doing,
it depends in tyler who you are.
Joe.
Well,
no,
with Usada it does not.
It depends entirely on what you're doing
now,
general terms here in terms of whether
or not you get punished twice for the
same crime.
So if they can prove exactly the same
way they approve with John the fuel,
one of the things is happening.
He said the testing is getting far
better
so they can test you for stuff now that
a year ago was absolutely impossible for
sure.
So the threshold right now that they
were saying this is where it's confusing
to me.
The threshold that they tested,
John was supposed to be more stringent
than Vada.
Yes.
And then the,
the night of the fight,
this is where it gets weird to me.
The night of the fight to commission
tested them all the same period,
same pice commission you,
Sada and Vada all test them.
St Piss.
You soughted didn't report anything.
Commissioned report anything,
right?
Andy Foster,
you clear them to fight.
But then Vada did,
does he found to have better testing?
Now it's all the same.
So how's that possible?
So you think shenanigans with you side
of yes,
I think he's shiniest.
Here's the other thing,
Joe.
Here's what no one talks about with you
Sada in the rule book,
no matter if it's Picos,
whatever is,
if you get flagged,
it doesn't matter if it's from residue,
whatever it is,
you cannot compete until that is out of
your body.
That's the rule book,
black and white.
It doesn't say,
well if it's Pico Graham,
just still good.
It doesn't matter.
Right?
But do you understand that he's not
testing positive for the actual
steroids?
Again,
that doesn't matter.
That tablet in the rule book,
it doesn't say that.
It says if you test pop regardless,
what is your weekend?
I for the metastasis,
we cannot grant you the license to
compete.
Interesting.
Which is interesting to me.
Well now I'm not saying they should.
This is why they don't suspect this.
Why?
I honestly think why they're doing this,
because they don't know exactly how this
is happening.
I think they have their,
their theories,
which you know,
it works right now,
but ultimately they don't really know
what's going on.
So if they were to suspend John and he's
really not taking shit,
he can sue the fuck out of him.
So I think that's what's going well.
There's that.
And then there's also this concept of
double jeopardy that they've already
punished him for having this stuff in a
system is no indication that he has
recently taken it.
But that's not the only hat,
Joe,
I understand.
But they're making the rules up as they
go along,
which is an issue because if this was
corey Anderson,
phenomenal fighter,
not the same drawing powers.
John,
what happens at Galileo?
The words word,
the argument,
the evening,
if they're making it up as they go
along,
the parameters are changing.
So the ability to test things is
changing.
So if someone takes,
say you take creatine,
creatine is tainted and you'd have some
forbidden substance in your system and
it's supposed to only stay in your
system for six months if it's this
certain stuff,
but now the testing gets better and so
now instead of punishing you for
something that you accidentally took and
then they test you and they say,
oh,
we can prove that you accidentally took
it,
so we'll only going to give you a six on
suspension,
but then after the six months is over,
they could still test it in you.
Why?
Because the testing has gotten better.
What do they do now?
Because in the past they would've said,
well,
you've,
it's time served.
This is the only argument for the,
the John Jones thing that makes sense is
that you don't want,
you want,
you don't want to punish a guy for
something you've already punished him
for.
If you proven that it's,
this is what he took with the,
but the at the rule book is it's you can
only compete when you pass the tab.
You read this rule.
Yes.
Um,
yeah.
I did discussion this morning with me
and channel went back forth on texts.
How does shale feel about this?
What does he think he shouldn't be
allowed to compete because his
understanding,
because still show no matter what you
meant to take it or not,
right,
right.
The rule is if you do not pass the test,
we can't grant you're licensed to fight.
That is the rules as explained to most
all the fighters separate job.
The real problem would be is what if
it's proven at some point in time,
let's just say a big for riff.
What if rather,
what if it's proven one time that they
can tell if you've ever taken anything
ever your whole life and they just
disqualify anyone forever.
Even if he'd snatch bullshit task.
But if that happened,
I know it's a problem.
You won't have a sport.
This thing is a weird thing.
This pulse,
here's the weird thing of the
metabolite.
They don't really understand.
Here's where it's weird.
It makes no sense.
With our youth thought of testing,
the Usada testing,
their parameters are based off a Olympic
testing,
right?
Based off suspending guys two to four
years.
You know how fucked up that is to do a
fighter like Josh Barnett that,
so how small is your window?
It's not,
we're not,
the Olympics doesn't come every four
years,
right?
It's such a small window.
You suspend these guys for two to four
years,
right?
It's fucking silly question.
But if a guy does juice and he hurts
someone and gets away with it and then
you catch them like you've been trying
to catch up and then you catch him,
how much should you suspend them for?
Save.
You got a guy who's hired some victor
content type individual back when victor
was doing this with the uh,
the clear and he some guy and this guy
gets him on some shit that no one knows
what it is and he's just running through
people and he's looking like Yoel Romero
and smashing people but,
and everybody's like,
I don't buy it.
Something's wrong.
And then one day you catch them,
you spend for food.
So he shouldn't have a career ever
again.
I don't know what she does.
Not with years.
That's ridiculous.
Cause we're going based off Olympic
curriculum.
What's the real question is like how
many people are cheating?
Right.
And what should the punishment be?
Should it be based on how many people
are cheating or she'd be based on the
philosophy we're trying to get cheating
out of the sport.
I don't know.
You ever can get it out.
And as you cited the answer,
cause obviously some shady,
do you wish,
do you wish that the Japanese were super
crazy strict about steroids back before
pride?
No.
No,
no,
no.
As a fan,
I think you saw as really wouldn't have
happened.
Right.
So Anderson was making a point the other
day in a rational point for letting a
guy like him take something so that he
could recover.
You know,
cause he's 40 years old,
he still enjoys fighting,
but his body doesn't produce
testosterone in the right way anymore.
Correct.
He's been trained.
He's beat.
Whether you tried that for a while,
I remember they made that leap.
It was legal for awhile too,
are fucked it all up.
And I know over even before they're like
got to pass over.
He didn't have a testosterone use
exemption fee toward did he talk,
did it legitimately Dan Henderson deal
legitimate.
So a few other guys had hit a veto like
all right,
well the
way it works,
it's way worse.
They don't test you.
No,
it was like,
it was totally legal.
Just like insiders knew.
We knew where the key got it.
There was a guy in
our gym,
they're like,
he got trt pass.
We're like fuck man.
Yeah.
Kind of a big name and had to be in with
Dana and Lorenzo.
Yeah.
Like you can always be a guy.
Like what if they had like big veins on
their bicep and on their shoulder?
They had like that little spider vein.
You're like,
damn,
motherfuckers though.
We were so jealous.
I was like,
I want trt exam.
Get it.
Like you got to know someone at
[inaudible] to be fucking around.
But no one believed that.
It was like a conspiracy theory was
like,
no way.
They allow it.
He goes,
yeah,
dude,
if you have a doctor's note,
you could fucking Dude Tiara and why
not?
And no one would believe it.
It was like,
dude,
you're full of shit.
It was a tinfoil hat conspiracy.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
I think the conspiracies all with Usada.
It just got exploited in,
everybody was tripping on that doctor's
note.
What trt.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and when they put us down for a while
there,
it was fucking legal.
Sure was.
How crazy and it was awesome.
He had a doctor's note,
but it was awesome.
And now it's too strict and it's fucking
things.
I'm guys,
I have to do other shit and they're
getting caught.
How would,
how would you like it if you got to be
the president of MMA and you saw to kick
rocks?
It's just making it more complicated.
We'll put the money elsewhere.
It's honestly not.
What do you do about steroid testing?
You just don't of do it.
How Bell Tory.
Yeah.
How does Bela Tarr do it?
Just has the commission do it.
So basically means yes,
you gotta be a moron to get caught by
the commission.
So if you're going to do shit,
wait a minute,
I didn't know if there wasn't a Usada
and state would have their own,
the commission would be responsible for
it.
Correct.
And what is it?
They just don't know how to do them
right.
They don't do it as strict.
You get tested,
you know,
they don't do it weeks before.
They don't come randomly.
You get tests that,
you know when you weigh in or the day of
the fight in the,
after the fight.
And so what if,
what if fighters used to do,
they could get it out of your tasting
off.
Yeah.
Oh,
reward.
But there are certain states like la or
New Jersey was super strict.
So guys,
I chill.
Sony Dot.
Cotton California.
Oh,
I dunno who Keith.
Keith Thurman.
He fought tonight on Fox.
It should be all it started at six.
Maybe not.
Maybe there's some fights on before it.
There was,
but it's not.
It's midnight on the east coast.
Foxes done.
So,
um,
see Keith Thurman?
It is.
I'll check.
Was It on Fox?
So what it was,
what was it?
ESPN sober.
Who won?
Yeah.
Tryna fine.
What'd you guys talk about?
Japanese sweet.
Did your boys back tonight?
Oh,
won.
hold on,
hold on.
I know Keith tweeted that.
Yeah.
Retains title fight for him for God
sakes.
And everyone to see him.
Verse Earl Spence.
But it'll spend spiky Brendan,
if he was the king or the president of
MMA,
how would he,
what would he do about the steroids
situation?
And he said he would get rid of Usada
correct.
And then words and then have the
commission see in her that the
commission test,
which basically means that,
uh,
all you gotta do is just be,
you know,
it's a stupid,
he careful you're still going to do
shit,
but none of the fight you're clean night
of the fight,
the fight that well when dad pay a clean
from a piss test.
Oh okay.
I I think,
I think is that how they used to do it?
Well that's how they did it when I
fought,
when alice or fought brock,
he was clean,
you know,
he tested clean cause it was a very
simple urine test.
It was like quest labs type shit.
You got a job at ups and I'm checking
you from mushrooms.
The commission do
Spanish.
That's how Bellah toward does it.
They just,
it's a belt.
You just don't really,
let me ask you this.
Did anybody ever approached you and
said,
hey man,
I think we can,
uh,
we can get you on some stuff.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
They say,
how did they say it?
Uh,
it was like locker room talk like a,
they're like,
Yo,
I got this guy,
dude,
he's great.
He does this,
this,
this.
I can afford it at the fire.
Yeah.
That's how it starts with a yeah.
Or a coach would,
we'd be like,
hey man,
you know you could do this.
This,
I can afford it though.
How much are they talking?
Uh,
I dunno cause they were going through
like a doctor and I just remember herr
doctor.
I don't think he's still in business and
uh,
I remember that.
Like your insurance won't it.
So you got paid cash.
I remember her ass and I met at the
time.
I was like,
Oh fuck,
that's a car payment man.
There's no way I couldn't do it.
Oh,
what I've done it probably,
yeah,
probably a short window.
Man.
Bob Sapp is up to lately.
It's a good question.
It's a fucking girls in Japan.
He's on weedy boxes and dressing up as
scouts to the,
had a real problem in Japan.
He know he had to leave.
Oh for the,
you'll get a k one fight and they
wouldn't let him sign a contract before
he fought.
He's like,
I'm not fighting without a contract.
And they said,
first you fight,
then we give you a contract.
And it was just like,
so he walked out on the finals and it
was the end of him.
Bob Sapp would become a huge star in
Japan and I don't think he'd do in
America.
Completely understood.
I mean he was like,
he was on literally cereal boxes,
big billboards.
He had fucking figurines made up of,
I mean he's like,
what is a comparable celebrity in the
United States?
So super athlete maybe,
you know,
like who would be big right now?
He was so big and he was such an oddity
because he was literally 370 pounds with
after seeing not those little Japanese
girls just sucking them on.
Good luck.
It luck God.
And he probably,
yeah.
Oh Dude.
He,
you imagine,
I remember the fiesta who's twice sketch
that we wrote design it.
We wrote it as look at him.
So he's still fighting this.
There's a couple of years ago.
Yeah.
If he,
if he's doing well,
he was a pro.
He was a prom,
but it's still looks big.
He's still giant is giant again.
Does he tap from mount?
No,
I think he'd be was,
he was always a little bit of a damn.
He's got a belly.
But dude,
when fought Noguera he was about his
fucking scary as a guy.
Do you have that guys in shape that he's
fighting?
He almost broke no gears back to the
land and I'm on his head.
Remember that pile driver?
Yeah.
Gear up for a long time.
For Life.
He,
I see so fucked up from it.
Yeah.
He really hit some problems.
That's Christine's through on,
I mean,
Bob Sapp was so big,
so ginormous.
Such a nightmare.
Like what do you do with that?
And because he was on everything,
his fucking cardio wasn't the worst,
that best fighter's heart.
But he's just such fucking silence.
Yeah.
Where,
yeah.
But if the fight went for a long time,
That was an issue.
He didn't fight it for a while.
Well,
you know,
and after a while he took a bunch of
beatings and he's like,
gets it good.
That's enough.
Go back to the truck.
I'm broke.
His eyeball,
Cro,
cop smashes eyeball.
I remember when I was opening more than
the other.
I was cause they get that orbital is
fucked man.
When people get their orbital smashed,
almost always like anything more behind
one I began,
I call it the sniper.
You don't want the fucking one I bigger
than the other.
The other one bigger?
I don't think so.
Is there surgeries?
Tell him to go in there and fucking
straighten out that eyeball.
Don't want the sniper bro.
Yeah,
I thought that was the oh Vaughn for a
second.
That's up.
Gender liquid.
Your hair cut,
son.
Gender neutral.
You don't know what I am.
That's Marky mark ironing clothes.
Oh this is for brothers.
Good movie.
All adopted mom gets murdered and they
have to avenge her death in Detroit,
Michigan.
I remember this movie.
You're like,
I am DB that did I know my database.
It's useless.
I get nineties references for four days.
So we wrapped this pitch up.
So I think so man Pinto around me out
fade or it didn't bum me out.
I mean the fucking sucks for him for
sure.
Suck them off so hard before that fight.
But for corrals it's a great thing.
And for,
for martial arts,
when something like that happens,
every young fighter gets another little
piece of information in his database of
experiences that he can at least view,
maybe not have,
but view and put that in your mind.
Okay,
this is what happens when you throw
caution to the wind and you just slug it
out with somebody.
When you just slug it out,
you stand right in front of somebody.
Sometimes you get knocked out to bad
idea and you know,
I mean he was winning the fight.
Up until that moment he'd cracked the
guys,
he had hurt him,
he looked amazing and then boom,
he's standing.
I mean he's so good,
but he's still human.
And that's just the reality of being a
human being that's fighting and I'm
bummed out.
Yeah,
I get it.
Cause you know the guy,
Um,
I can't say that I think those,
those experiences,
it's not good for him.
Right.
Cause it happened again,
getting knocked down for anybody got
hurt bad.
But it's,
it's valuable for all of us to take in.
What happens when,
you know,
look,
every time I got gets knocked out,
believe it or not,
it's valuable for the overall database
of martial
arts.
Yeah.
Even a striker Mirko Cro cop has decided
on at least two fights,
I think,
where he decided,
you know what?
I think I have a better shot taken this
motherfucker down.
Sure.
And throwing elbows on the ground from
the Taco Taco.
You know what I mean?
That was like a strategy that he
thought,
you know what,
I'm getting clipped every now and then.
It's like Russian roulette.
Even he's one of the greatest strikers
of all time,
one of the most dangerous motherfuckers
out there.
And he even got to the point where he
was like,
you know what?
I think I'll have a better shot taking
this motherfucker down and smashed them.
Even vandelay Silva did that once or
twice.
Sure.
You remember when cro cop fought random
and random and chaotic and random mom
was known as more of a wrestler,
but you know,
he's a fucking stud athlete.
Literally.
It's the best sport.
Well,
it's certainly the craziest to watch me
with.
Pico got knocked out.
We all jumped out of our chairs.
I fell on the ground.
We all walked around on the ground.
I believe.
It's crazy.
It's a crazy fucking sport,
man.
A crazy sport.
You know?
How crazy is it that we all work in it
somehow?
Like what happened?
They're like,
my family is fucking still confused.
How the fuck is anybody paying you tie
how to fight?
I Dunno.
I'm pulling it off.
It's weird.
My family does not,
does not.
I left my family as a musician,
not theirs as a pussy who never got into
any fights.
I got in a couple of fights,
but I wasn't known as a fighter.
Right.
You know what I mean?
I,
I wrestled a couple of years so I
thought I was cheating when I would find
I would just double legged d dude and
punch him in the stomach until the
teacher broke it up tight.
But I was never ever considered a
dangerous guy at all by my family,
by my closest friends that I grew up.
So even today they're like,
they still like,
man.
How did you pull that off dude?
Like what the fuck?
I'm like,
dude,
I don't know.
I got lucky.
You paid attention to it.
You know I got fucking lucky.
Good pat though because it shows
everybody that if you really just learn
something,
you get good at it.
You keep getting better at it.
You keep acquiring information,
testing yourself,
really being obsessed with it.
You eventually,
one day after years of training,
you become a fucking wizard at it.
Whatever it is in comparison to how you
were when you first started.
It doesn't matter what you do,
like stand up like you,
you doing standup to your dude.
You did two years in,
you did a fucking showtime special.
Me and Brian were in the back room.
We were shaking our head.
He's like two years anyway.
That's incredible.
But you put in the fucking work,
you started out,
you were uncomfortable at first.
She got better and better.
You kept working on it.
He chipped away at it.
You were constantly,
constantly doing sets,
constantly going over your material and
you pulled it off.
Got The nma work ethic with comedy.
Yes,
and it pro athlete f work ethic,
but it's,
it's that thing.
It's good for people to see.
I know it feels bad if you're not doing
anything in your life.
And I was one of the things that people
do when they hate,
once these two people do,
when they hate,
like if you're kicking ass,
they get upset because they're not and
they're looking at you like you're not
that good or you're not that this.
You'd have to,
sometimes those criticisms are valid,
but at the end of the day,
the reason why they're expressing them
as a,
as exuberantly as they are is because
they're find flaws in their own life
that they don't like to address.
And when they see someone that's doing
well,
they,
they go after them.
They shit on what I'm trying to say.
It's natural.
It is an incident.
Natural.
I'm not,
what I'm trying to say though is for all
those people,
if you just stop putting any energy into
that stock,
it doesn't help you.
I've done it before.
I did it when I was younger.
I 100% guilty of what I'm saying,
but it's a waste.
It's a giant waste of time.
If you just get better at stuff,
just find a thing,
whatever.
That if can see too,
if it's stand up comedy or whatever it
is,
just find that thing and keep going.
Just keep going.
My fave trade or getting better.
My favorite is when people go rogue and
righteous shit.
I'm like,
yeah,
yeah.
Rhoden wrote the hour from me.
Yeah,
that's exactly what he did.
I had the time to do that.
Yeah.
I'm barely,
that's my own comedy.
He's given my perspective and he's
writing it.
You fucking bad to stare.
That is impossible.
Impossible comedy doesn't work that
well.
You know who did do that though?
For a lot of guys will definitely do
that for Chris Rock was Richard Jeni,
Richard,
Jenny would tighten up dudes material.
He,
you would punch it up.
Yeah,
you would go do sets and he would sit in
the back of the room and he'd watch it.
But Hey,
you've got to drop that.
You've got to drop that to get rid of
that.
Just started with this and go into that
and he would give you this and guys are
just listened to it.
It's kind of cool like a cut.
Like some guys have done that,
you know,
crusher where like I,
I told him my story and he's like you,
but he doesn't say do this.
He'd go,
you're,
it's too long here.
Right,
right,
right.
Focused on this and do this.
They meaning like focus on all the time
on this back when I did,
uh,
the,
those few open mics,
like 15 years ago,
I remember I bombed so bad,
this one set and the r that you just
grabbed me and said,
follow me and you just drag me to the
back.
I had to tell you,
I'm to tell you,
so I was high and I had to tell you why
it was because when you're high like
thoughts,
they're slippery.
So mad not mad at you.
I was never mad at you.
No,
no,
no.
I was not disappointed.
But I recognize what that was.
Cause I had done it.
I've done it before.
You went in there,
it didn't go well and then you just
crashed and burned.
But what happened with you,
which is interesting,
is you got really good at talking
publicly.
And as you got better at talking
publicly and doing classes and teaching
classes,
then a transition back to,
to,
to stand up comedy actually made sense
because now you weren't nervous at all
because before you were always really
funny.
But the hard part was you being yourself
on stage.
And that's uh,
it's hard.
It's still,
and I had no public speaking experience.
That's huge.
I mean,
it's going to be rose zero public
speaking experience.
And I knew it and I thought,
you know what?
I'm going to have to really spend a lot
of fucking time,
uh,
with this if I'm going to do it right.
And I just didn't want to spend the
time,
so I decided,
you know what,
I can do it.
Let me just focus on Jujitsu.
You know,
he could do,
if you could,
if someone,
someone's going to do it eventually,
but if you could get joey diaz to for
it,
the,
his comedy to come off on a special,
like the same way he had all of us in
the back of the comedy store.
I'm doing some of that story.
I'll tell you after the show.
I'm town,
Dude.
I'll tell you after the show my,
I thought I broke my rib the next
morning.
I was laughing so hard.
I was in tears.
Yeah,
we have a plan.
My rebuttal was Ari and I were literally
just texting right before the show
started.
And that's kind of watches Netflix
special and not that anything's wrong
with,
he's still a fucking monster.
But if you could capture that man,
get that game over best in the world,
those netflix specials,
what they're doing is a half an hour set
they're doing with a bunch of other
people that they probably don't work
with a lot and they have two shots.
They have the first show and then they
have second show and sometimes it
doesn't work out as well.
It's hard.
You're under pressure.
It feels weird.
You're not used to the crab.
Maybe the,
the audience's lit up in a weird way.
It also gets lost in the shuffle though,
cause there's a ton of them on there.
You know what I'm saying?
Like Joey,
he's in with a bunch of other guys.
You,
you can't fault that because the ones
that stand out,
I mean look at whether you like it or
not.
Like a,
that Nanette thing from Hannah Gatsby.
I still haven't seen it,
but I know what stood out in a lot of
people liked it or not though.
Right,
okay.
But there was other ones that didn't
stand out for that,
but they stood out because people really
responded to it.
Tom,
yours,
I mean tom selling out these places
because people responded so well to his
special.
Oh No,
no,
I'm not sitting.
No,
Netflix is amazing.
I'm not saying,
I'm saying how his was released in
degenerates.
There's eight 30 minutes.
It's a package,
so it doesn't matter.
It really doesn't give us a lot about
Neal Brennan special from people that
watch three months while he was on
there.
That's right.
Comedians in the world.
Brendan's event set.
Neil Brennan Ready.
I want to say anything about his new
stuff because they'll give away the
premises,
but he's murdered that he's,
I'm not super impressed with Neal
Brennan.
I was like,
Whoa,
this is the funniest I've ever heard
him.
I love that.
Oh,
he's a,
he's very good.
He's definitely the best one I've seen
so far on that,
on that speech.
He's very smart man.
He's very smart and his new stuff is
excellent.
She has isis,
his analogy of Isis,
don't say it,
but yeah.
Yeah.
So good.
He punches up a lot of people.
Your favorite comedians?
Shit.
He punches up.
Yes.
Ellen's rock.
Chris Rock's Whitney.
He was Dave Chappelle's writing partner
for the Chapelle show.
Yeah,
that was back when we were friends with
him.
He hadn't even done stand up yet.
Remember that when we hung out with them
in New York and he came with me when I
did,
uh,
the fear factor,
Chappelle sketch,
we did a weird ass warehouse.
How long ago was this?
2004.
It was a long time ago.
What's it even,
it might might've been three.
So we fly out to New York and they're
filming all day in this fucking old ass
warehouse with no windows and it's
freezing every bodies in winter coats.
And we had a,
like one of those burner here,
things,
those portable like inferno here things.
Eddie and I were fucking huddled by this
time.
Everybody was the camera man,
the grips and the whole,
he did,
um,
the crackhead character,
Dave Chappelle.
Oh Shit.
Stayed,
he stayed in character the whole fucking
day and he's trying to tell him about
me.
Like he introduced me to Dave Chappelle
and goes,
this guy,
he just tapped Hoya gracie and uh,
he was like,
hi Gracie.
God Damn,
until the whole bill all.
Yeah.
So all,
every time we ran into each other
throughout the day,
he'd look at me and goes,
you tap wise.
Grazie he was just staring at us over
and over.
He would say the same shit.
I wonder why it took so long to get into
stand up.
He's such a brilliant mom.
I think he sat back and watched it and
probably thought he could do it and then
said,
no on,
let me just give it a shot.
And he just took to it like a duck to
water.
Yup.
Yeah.
But um,
I had a good conversation about standing
up with him last night.
I just saw Sebastian special yesterday,
last night.
Sebastian.
Excellent.
It's so crazy that we used to see,
we've seen him.
He was just one of the regulars at the
Olr when we'd go in like right after
this.
He just chose that one four shows at
Madison Square Garden.
Credible
thousand people a show.
He showed us
sold out for show top 10,
right?
For most uh,
yeah.
I said her name well this year he
probably be,
it's going to be number one fighting
gas.
Seinfeld's saying hold my beer.
No,
no,
no.
Sipho can't do that.
He can't sell out four shows at Madison
Square Garden like that.
He might sell at one flip.
Foresoft for is crazy.
There's guys like Louis C K and
capturing hell,
but Louie c Kathy sold out two in a row.
I don't think he ever did like four like
that and Chappelle's copyright to it and
it's a weekend dude.
He saw out for it.
It's insane.
It's almost unprecedent dice.
Did it die?
Sold out Madison Square Garden.
How many times?
I Dunno.
Kevin Hart's for coming onto,
the thing about dice that you always
have to give up is at dice was z numero
uno.
Nobody did that before.
Nobody did anything like that before
with dice done.
What he did,
he would sell out arenas when nobody had
even heard about doing this before.
Nassau Coliseum.
Even Eddie Murphy's dice.
Dice Murphy was close though,
right?
He was until he stopped doing standup.
But he never quite reached the heights
at dice did.
Dice was absolutely without a doubt.
Unprecedented cause I remember it was
happening as I was getting into standup,
but so he as I was getting into standup
dice was selling out arenas and he would
sell them out like two,
three nights in a row and they just had
done hundreds of arena shows all over
the country.
I mean nobody had been like that before.
Every before everybody was doing like
places that I used to do this kind of
like a different version,
a newer like cleaned up version of dice
sort of,
you know.
And when they used to go on the road
together,
Sebastian,
yeah.
It tells a story about not doing lot on
long enough set and have you heard this?
No.
Forget Sebastian talked about this.
He's opening for him and he goes,
he's supposed to do 12 minutes,
and he did eight and he came to the back
and dice just fucking tore him a new
one.
It was like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Well,
it's great to 12th yeah,
you'll do your shit.
Nice.
I guess ask is mine right?
Went to early.
Oh Dude,
I did a show with the guy wants,
I went to the green room and a minute
and a half later he came backstage.
It was great.
I go,
where are you?
It's great.
I go,
what did he do when he goes?
He just goes,
I can't do it.
You can't do it.
You're done.
Because yeah,
I'm just a tap.
I can't.
So I walked out through the green room
door onto the stage and the audience is
looking at me like,
what up?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
I remember that.
I remember that famous cat.
Oh,
young guy.
His name,
but the guy went out.
I remember that.
Yeah,
and then the whole night you were trying
to coach him back.
He was like,
I'm done with it.
I quit.
I'm never going to do this.
He should go out.
Well,
he just crowded.
What happened?
He used to do stand up and then he
stopped doing it.
Like it.
He had a regular job too and he wasn't,
wasn't doing it as much in need.
I think he was drinking,
but I know him when I know him.
Joe.
Oh No.
Good guy though.
I like him a lot.
He was a bomber.
Hopefully figure it out,
but like it's fucking hard man.
It's even harder in England,
man.
You want to make of New England.
It's not,
it's not as easy as it is.
If you ever had like just a nightmare
show like that,
like it was just horrible than not 1:00
AM I not.
Not that one of my one hours,
like if I'm on the road,
no,
if you bomb it there,
I don't know what you're doing.
But at the comedy story,
I've ate all the ticks in the room.
All right,
coming to see you there.
That's what I'm saying.
When I'm on the road though.
Those are my people.
But that's why the comedy store,
the laugh factory have eight tons of
ticks.
Those are so important.
Those weird shows.
15 people on the lineup and they might
be there to see deleah.
They might be due to see
joey.
Scary Shit.
That's the only way.
That's what you're supposed to do with
the other night.
And uh,
you know,
it wasn't my crowd like I could notice
right away there's old people in the
back.
Oh,
it was kind of,
you know,
draw on pills.
Yeah.
It's better when they're there to see
those.
Is that whiskeys fucking good?
It's good whiskey one another one.
Ah,
I got to drive that.
Thinks fast as fuck.
How funny he was doing.
Stand up.
It's the fun.
It's shit.
It's the funny shit when you don't bomb
and when it goes great.
It's a,
it's too much fun.
Dude.
Last Saturday,
my special,
so Rogan introduced me.
I come out in the crowd,
so awesome.
Oh and A,
I start getting emotional like I,
my eyes start fill up with tears.
I'm like,
fuck dude.
Fuck.
Do not cry.
Do not fucking so they'll definitely use
the edit of the second show cause I
didn't get emotional because I had to
find my way in that first one.
It gives a great crowd too,
man.
They were super hyped.
It was really fun.
It was so cool.
Count went up until like 10 minutes,
10 minutes.
I really stepped off the side and then a
proper ended up.
Yeah,
it was awesome,
man.
We were so proud of you.
Yeah,
so cool.
So cool.
It was so fun,
man.
In my life,
You sound super positive,
man.
Dude.
I drove all the way the fuck down and
all the way the fuck back and I can't
believe you did that.
I drove five and a half hours down in
two and a half hours back,
eight hours of driving son.
It was rough.
That's how I got home.
I'm like,
I got my head out the window trying to
stay awake,
face imagining how good that bed is
going to feel.
You're just like,
fuck dude.
I told you I'd get you a route,
whatever you want to Berta flying a
helicopter.
But he's like,
no,
you might get back dog.
It would have been great.
It's been great.
How much would a helicopter ride?
I Dunno.
I offered it.
I had to drive.
My daughter had a gymnastics event and
so I was going to get back.
Yeah.
How to get back in the morning.
I got emotional before the thing,
cause obviously you shown up Brian,
my boys and then theo send me this
videos,
heartfelt veal Deleah Bert Thompson
girl.
Like,
I'm like,
what the Fuck Joey Diaz?
And I'm like,
what the fuck man.
It's just that when you were like,
hey man,
you know,
you don't have to come like,
listen motherfucker,
I'm coming.
I'm like,
I'm not,
I'm not going to mess that.
I need to see that.
It was fun.
It was a good night.
It was very positive,
positive vibes.
I was,
I was beaming like half the way home
until I started getting tired.
I was super happy,
so happy.
Where does it come out?
Uh,
I would say may,
may or April.
So you got a tour now and then try to
work in new material while you're
touring.
Here's the thing,
I'm,
no,
I'm not going on the road to March.
I have and you're gonna be like,
you're a fucking idiot.
I almost have seen because I record this
special.
I'm done with that man.
So I'm,
I'm trying to,
I'll still do,
obviously I have to do certain bids when
I did the store,
but I'm trying to get at least 30
minutes before you should.
Um,
but it's not a bad idea to do the road
while you still can because you can make
money doing clubs and theaters and all
the different than reps.
And the,
the strategy that I always employed,
it's not the best one.
You can do whatever you want,
but what I like to do is do a bit that I
know works and then some new shit and
then a bit,
I know we're responding to new shit.
Shit Sandwich.
Correct.
And then eventually after events,
yeah,
I turned that shit into beef jerky and
then eventually it's a steak.
Yup.
Just takes time.
Yeah.
But that's the best way I've found is
to,
you got to give him some stuff that's
100% legit or have to,
I do.
I definitely still do workout sets like
in town where there's fucking around.
But even now it's like,
what if I do a workout side of the
store?
Like a lot of times it's mobbed,
man.
I mean there's a story.
Can I can't do my job,
my mom and that made them good shit.
And you go on stage and they go fucking
crazy.
Like they'd got babysitters,
Bro.
I got a plan cause that horrible
anxiety.
Literally the next morning I woke up at
the worst thing,
anxiety.
I'm like,
I come up with all new shit.
I don't,
I got a plan cause I feel better about
it.
I don't bump people,
but I understand
it because with a guy like Chris Rock or
Louis C K or a lot of the guys that
would would,
um,
when I say bump,
it's not thought of as a negative thing.
It's thought of as a negative thing if
you really don't deserve it.
Right?
Like if you're a certain person who
tried to bump people and people like
this fucking guy is pumping people.
But you know if Chris rock shows up,
generally most people just let them go
on stage and Dave Chapelle perfect
example and it just let him go.
He's already spent,
but it's awesome.
It's complete respect.
But what it is,
it's how they managed to try stand up
when they know it's not their audience.
Like they're famous.
So it's almost like every audience is
Dave Chappelle's audience home games.
But that's how you develop material
because if you,
if people are common to see you 100% and
then you feel more inclined to do new
stuff,
whereas if you just drop it in,
you feel like you could work on new
stuff better.
If people come to see rather you,
you're going to,
you're going to do stuff that's tried
and proven.
I caught him last his and it was in the
or I was leaving and I pass by and I'm
like,
Oh shit.
Dave Chappelle's onstage and everybody,
I mean,
there was so much God damn loving,
positive energy in that room because,
and he was just sitting on a chair
smoking a cigarette and he was just
standing recruiting.
He said people lost their fucking mind.
Like one line he was,
he would just sit there,
don't ever tell your wife's gay friends
shit.
And then
they didn't even have to hear the rest
of the story.
Everybody.
Comedians.
Yeah.
It's like,
fuck did he so good,
so confident.
He's just,
he's like the fucking Yoda.
You know,
comedy is just incredible.
He's is good as anybody that's ever
lived.
Yeah.
Hell fucking yeah.
And he's got his own style to this laid
back,
you know,
so confident.
Just calm and silly and knows he's going
to kill.
It's like impossible.
I love how he wears his own clothes.
You noticing like,
so this is a Gucci fucking shirt,
right?
He would have that Gucci sign taken off
and it says,
uh,
Dave d c he has his logo on it,
all his clothes to see.
Right.
Is it just as you see it's just,
see it's just a c on all his clothes and
just fucking Jean.
Jacques is genes you have notice cause
he get those clothes made.
I think it's his own wine.
I'm not sure,
but I don't obviously I'm a weird
fashion dude gets closer.
We shirts my shirts all the time though.
His is like designer shit.
Like he like his Jean Jacket.
We'll just have his logo on it.
His chain will be his logo.
Really shirt will be as low as smart as
fuck.
He's like,
why am I going where other people's
shit.
Well it's also like
you don't want to get caught up in that
designer name trap where people are
trying to wear Gucci everywhere and all
these different,
you know what I'm saying?
Like people get caught up in that where
they have,
yeah,
show that off.
It's fucking stupid.
Yeah.
Wouldn't you rather have a big old be on
everything?
Did
she go for it?
Don't you go buy Goethe?
No,
dolce now.
Okay.
What is,
what's top of the line?
Gucci is Gucci.
Gucci.
Louis Vuitton in probably six months
with Virgil's release.
He's the head crater now.
They're going to take go,
fuck.
Did you just say,
I know Jamie can understand them.
Do you understand Jamie?
He's on black twitter.
Gucci.
What?
What else is the shit?
Gucci off whites.
Huge right now.
Kratos still good.
Proud of what it's like.
Are there certain watches the guys try
to wear?
Rolex is always killing it.
Oh,
this is never going to go and it never
goes anywhere.
You gotta I stop role lax and you're a
rapper.
You're a winner.
Yeah.
Yeah,
right.
Oh always.
But tone is classic.
But if you're like a floyd mayweather,
you gotta take it to a two level for Tom
can cube the lower tall.
He wears a Louis Vuitton or Gucci all
time Gucci ski like caught in the
streets.
That's number one.
She's like,
it's a crossover.
How do you know this?
Because the,
their style,
it's just,
you'll see in the magazines.
Is there like where's it coming?
It's just like how do you do out there?
I don't know.
It's just you have your finger in the
past.
But where's the,
where's the,
what magazine do you have to read?
Paul says like what kind of the pulse
will start with like what's the website?
This is going to be,
this is him with this is millions of
dollars with a watch has played this
cause it's so preposterous starting from
the beginning and play it.
He's so ridiculous.
He's got like 30 watches with it.
But can you do it from the beginning?
What's that?
I can't start it over.
Okay,
look at this.
Do you know what the kind of security
has to any of this?
Well,
do you know what you know what was
crazy?
Three days.
30 watches.
10 more days.
I Take Tim more watches Jesus Christ.
But then I say fuck it.
If I want to bring up the one and only
you're not bringing out the wash,
their cost.
18 million.
Ah Oh my God.
That's so preposterous.
$18 million on your wrist.
That's insane.
Plus the press play,
Jamie.
Fuck you.
You motherfucker.
Hey,
just today I'm you go fuck off $50,000
cause I ain't got shit else to do.
Mother fuckers money May,
oh all mother fucking day.
That's the end retake is crazy million
dollar watch 50 cent or is that an act?
It's a good question.
That's a real thing.
I think they were really mad at each
other.
Yeah.
I don't think
a lot of people get in.
And is it a little scraps?
Yeah,
I dunno.
Floor.
He gets them scraps.
Well,
you know,
I mean when you act like that,
that's his,
this whole thing in Asia.
But the problem is like Adrian broner
tries doing the same thing,
but he doesn't win.
So it's tough.
You know his,
his club,
his,
I think his slogans about billions.
Adrian boner ab about billions.
It's tough.
It's a tough sell.
Well,
if he was light and everybody up on
fire,
sorry.
Well Little Shit.
Jamie's mixing it up.
A Dj Jv.
Jay was at black twitter.
He's talking about Adrian Broder.
Y'All know I beat that boy.
He said what?
What is 50 cents?
And as he's talking shit about Adrian.
Oh Damn.
Ab.
I want my money.
I bet on you back.
Oh look at this 50 cents.
The guy that just jumps in to stay
relevant.
Huh?
That's a little bit of it.
Like he's trolling and he gets his name
out.
Well,
he definitely does that.
Yeah.
Damn.
He's still do these days.
He's looks like he's got a bunch of
parties he's doing,
he's on power.
Right?
Power.
Those are shows a launch party.
So he's got a brand brandon,
if he owns that club.
Yeah,
I think he's doing parties.
I don't think he's necessarily like
rapping there.
No,
he's not.
Doesn't rap anymore.
Right.
Does he rap now?
He's an actor,
right?
He's on power.
And then he made a shitload of money off
vitamin water,
they say,
although that might be a rumor because
they said he's bullshitting you might be
an investor in beltour some he's going
to code like what is he doing with no
involved in it?
They,
it's almost like he's doing that same
shit that,
uh,
what was the girl Carmen Electra?
Did you know?
We were like a celebrity,
remember when she was,
uh,
connected to the UFC?
Electra was,
yeah.
You don't remember any,
she was post fight interview or
something?
No,
no,
no.
She was the liaison.
She was like a celebrity,
like,
uh,
she was,
like a promoter,
celebrity promotive UFC.
I want to say he's a manager.
He's my manager.
I want to say I wasn't working for the
UFC then.
Yeah.
See,
look at her.
Carmen Electra with two of those.
Jens pulver chocolate.
Yeah.
Wow.
Joe His,
Oh,
who's the other guy behind her?
Who's the guy behind her?
Look solely at rainbow.
Look at that picture.
Crazy.
That was current culture.
So like that Carmen Electra was like,
uh,
you know,
she was a hot celebrity on 10 hottest
small.
She would do these interviews and she
would talk about the UFC.
Yeah,
dude,
I'm all about that.
Bring that shit back.
They tried it for a little while,
but I don't think they got a lot of
mileage out of it and so they bailed on
the bad idea.
All right.
She's so hot.
Um,
yeah.
Well she was really nice too.
I did a thing with her or for Spike TV
back in the day.
We did some car thing.
You fucking kid rock and spike every
single at the time.
No,
sorry.
Well that ends this shit.
I don't think she was either,
so it's all right.
They,
you can figure it out.
You know this podcast is brought to you
by t fat K.
Dot Com.
Brendan shop be out in the road.
I'm not on the road to March.
We can check below before between now
and they just write right new shit.
The new shit set sets online sets sets
up.
I got a going up Tuesday,
I think Tuesday,
Wednesday.
I'm doing the late show and I'm doing
the early show.
Sam Termination show running store may
be.
I'll be there.
Mother fuckers.
All right.
Uh,
that's it.
Everybody.
A 10th planet.
J j.com.
Eddie Bravo 10
on Instagram at Eddie Bravo.
10 Pe,
10 P on instagram and Eddie Bravo
regular on twitter.
Do you go to twitter anymore?
I'm never on twitter.
I post shit that gets posted on twitter,
but I never met him.
Never mingle on twitter.
It's just instagram,
too toxic.
There's a bunch of it,
and actually this,
the grammar is just so much better.
All right.
Shout out to Marky mark and four
brothers,
whatever it is.
Yeah.
Shout out to Ryan Bader.
Ryan Bader.
Holy Shit.
She's this double champ,
champ babies.
You know what it is?
The philly cheese steak.
I'm below the belt probably.
Yeah,
and you could see that on showtime and
the goal of the belt.
The belt.
Youtube.
Okay.
Bye Buddy.